Hi.
Ich nicht sanci.
Wow, was machst du denn für Sachen? Eben warst du noch da und hast reden gehalten. Eben bist du noch mit einem Bündel Plastiktüten in die Clubräume gewatschelt und hast schelmenhaft die jüngsten Anekdoten berichtet. Und du hast gelacht und gegräult und gepoltert und gelacht. Und es war dir wichtig. Mensch, wow. Gerade bist du doch noch über den Kongress gelaufen und hast gewarnt und gelobt, gepriesen und verdammt, hast deinen Scham versprüht und Fragezeichen generiert, hast widersprochen und bist immer freundlich geblieben. Und wieder hast du aus deiner Welt berichtet, die ja die unsere ist, aber in der wir nicht immer alles gesehen haben, bis du uns darauf gebracht hast. Das hast du gut gemacht, wow. Mensch, wow. Dein Rat war uns wichtig. Deine Erinnerung war die Bibliothek unserer kleinen Welt, in der wir so viel bewegen wollen, in der wir mit dir auch viel bewegt haben und in der wir nun alles ohne dich bewegen müssen. Das wird uns ohne dich nicht leichter fallen. Mensch, wow, du wirst uns fehlen. Wer soll uns jetzt beraten? Wer soll die Grundsatzfragen beantworten? Wer soll die andere Meinung vertreten? Wer die Kontroverse führen, uns den Kopf waschen, wenn wir wieder mal nicht verstanden haben? Mensch, wow, du warst so vieles. Fragesteller und Infragesteller, die ewige Jugend und das weise Alter, ein Polarisierer und der Integrator. Und immer warst du uns ein guter Freund. Aber eins warst du vor allem und wirst es für uns immer bleiben. Der Mensch, wow.
Chaosradio 63 auf Fritz, Viertel nach Zehn ist es. Im Studio Tim, Martin, Chris und Lisa und die reden heute mit euch über Viren und natürlich auch mit mir, mein Name ist Holger Klein. Was war das für ein Text eben Tim? Ich glaub ein bisschen was müssen wir erklären für die, die nicht genau wissen wer Wau war.
Ja also am Sonntag früh ist halt der Mitgründer des CCC und unser Alterspräsident war Holland verstorben, nach einer knapp zweimonatigen Krankheit, nach einem Schlaganfall genau zu sein. Und auch wenn es eine Weile lang so aussah, als ob er sich davon wieder erholen könnte, hat es dann doch nicht stattgefunden. Vor ein paar Tagen hat ihn halt ein starkes Fieber ereilt und dazu war sein Körper dann zu schwach. Das trifft uns natürlich tief und die Stimmung ist halt dementsprechend. Aber wenn wir irgendwas schulden, dann schalten wir ihm halt, dass wir weitermachen. Ja, wer sich weiter informieren möchte zu Vau, geht einfach auf www.ccc.de. Es gibt dort ein Kondolenzbuch, in das man sich eintragen kann. Wir suchen auch noch Zitate von Vau, irgendwie für eine zukünftige Biografie.
Ja, da kann man dazu jetzt auch nichts sagen.
Dieses Chaosradio 63, noch mal guten Abend. Genau. Wir haben ja auch ein Thema. Mit Tim, mit Martin, mit Chris und mit Lisa und wir haben ein Thema, genau Viren. Viren und Würmer oder auch malicious code. Das heißt Linux zählt dazu, ja? Weil Bill Gates mal gesagt, das wäre sich viral verbreitendes Software.
Ja, der muss es doch wissen. Sicherlich eine gewisse Bedrohung für ihn, von daher mag er durchaus Recht haben. Aber letzten Endes geht es natürlich schon so um eine bestimmte Art von Software, die auch nicht neu ist, aber die halt immer wieder irgendwie gefeiert wird, als wäre sie irgendwie das erste Mal auf diesem Planeten. Eben Software, die irgendein anderes Software infiziert. Daher eben der Name Virus, dieser Vergleich, der sich dann gleich populär genug war. Man trifft die Sache auch ganz gut, weil es halt irgendwie nicht nur ein Programm ist, was böse ist, sondern was eben insbesondere, also was böse sein könnte, sondern was irgendwie dadurch sich schon mal etwas auffällig verhält, weil es halt sich irgendwie hinterwurfs auf andere Programme draufschwingt oder eben auch sehr elegante, oder auch weniger elegante Methoden benutzt, um irgendwie in ein System automatisch einzusteigen. Klassische Tätigkeit irgendwie, die den Hackern halt immer unterstellt wird, das Programm geht halt kindautomatisch durch.
Ja aber irgendjemand muss es ja dann mal geschrieben haben.
Ja natürlich. Klar.
Ja.
Genau. Wie heißt diese Konfusion, die neuere Chris?
Die neueste Konfusion, die heißt Code Red, die zurzeit ihr Unwesen treibt. Ist aber nicht ganz...
Das ist doch nur eine Finte vom FBI, oder? Die haben ja auch Pearl Harbor cofinanziert, nur um ihren Raketenschutzschild mit sie zu kriegen.
Wenn man so sieht, dann kann man das natürlich dem FBI unterstellen. Aber es ist schon eine relativ reelle Gefahr. Auch wenn der Hype jetzt in letzter Zeit etwas übertrieben war, also gerade jetzt zum Anfang des Monats, sprich heute und morgen. Aber an sich ist es schon eine reelle Bedrohung, die tatsächlich vorhanden ist. Obwohl man natürlich zum Kotret sagen muss, das ist kein klassischer Virus, wie wir vorhin besprochen hatten, sondern Kotret ist ein Wurm. Sprich, der unterscheidet sich durch ein Virus vor allem dadurch, dass er sich vollautomatisch verbreitet. Sprich, dass da kein Benutzer nötig ist, der irgendwie noch ein Programm anstatten muss, sondern dass sich so ein Wurm automatisch weiterverbreitet.
Liebe Waffungfreunde, holt jetzt mal alle eure Eltern und Großeltern ins Radio. Wir erklären jetzt mal den Unterschied zwischen einem Virus und einem Wurm, wie wär's?
Das ist ein bisschen gewagt.
Das wär doch auch was für die Bildzeitungsredakteure, die könnten wir noch so mal erklären.
Wir erklären jetzt mal den Unterschied zwischen einem Virus und einem Wurm, das ist tatsächlich sehr gewagt, weil das kaum zu machen ist. Also es gab da mal irgendwann Definitionen, aber es gibt halt so jede Menge bösartige Software, die nicht so richtig, wo man nicht so richtig sagen kann, ob es ein Virus ist oder ein Wurm oder beides oder irgendwas ganz anderes.
Warum kann man es nicht sagen?
Na die Grenzen sind doch sehr unscharf. Das hängt doch so ein bisschen mit den Verbreitungsmöglichkeiten zusammen und in was für Umgebungen diese Viren und Würmer laufen. Und der DOS war früher zum Beispiel mit den Viren mehr verbreitet. Und Würmer gibt es eher so in Unix Systemen.
Na also bei Server, also wir klatschen ja Server an und Viren meistens klein. Also eine klassische Definition ist halt noch, dass Viren einen Wirt brauchen, also ein Wirtprogramm und Würmer sind eigenständige Programme. Hab ich heute noch mal nachgeguckt und zum Beispiel diese eine Definition gefunden, was aber auch total schwammig ist und auch viele Viren, die so nennen lassen, gar nicht.
Ein Programm, das läuft, braucht ja eh ein Wirtprogramm.
Ja gut, ein Betriebssystem, also ein Wirt. Ich meine manchmal ist auch das Betriebssystem der Wirt völlig offen, wo sich ein Virus einklingt, das hängt natürlich dann auch von den Schutzmechanismen ab, die so ein Betriebssystem irgendwie liefert, aber wenn man sicherlich noch was zu erzählen können. Generell, ein Virus ist halt, also die Virenkultur ist entstanden auf Desktop-Systemen, vor allem unter DOS, aber natürlich auch auf anderen Systemen, wie irgendwie Amiga und anderen Systemen, wo es halt eigentlich früher gar keine Netzwerke gab. Also ich meine, es war ja de facto so, dass diese Rechner gar nicht miteinander vernetzt waren, von daher war diese klassische Wurmaktivität des sich über das Netzverbreiten gar nicht möglich in Ermangelung eines Netzes. Während die Wurmkultur begonnen hat, mehr oder minder eigentlich im Internet, da gibt es diesen Famous Internet Worm von einem Robert T. Morris, ich weiß nicht, Robert irgendwas Morris, der seinerseits glaube ich auch der Sohn eines Security Menschen war.
Ich glaube, der war im wissenschaftlichen Bereich tätig bei der NSA.
Ein bisschen lauter müsstest du sprechen, Lisa, dann versteht man auch, was du gesagt hast. Sie hat dann gesagt, ach ist doch nicht so wichtig, dann brauchst du es auch nicht sagen.
Ja und sein Vater wurde auch dadurch bekannt, dass er dieses Unix-Skript mitentwickelt hat.
Ah, genau, die Geschichte. Und er hat halt immer so rumgebastelt und hat halt irgendwie Schwachstellen von den klassischen Programmen. Es war Sendmails, es war glaube ich Finger. Also so eine Kombination von eben typischen Unix-Programmen, die auf Unix-Computern vorhanden waren und sozusagen auch nur über das Netz sozusagen angreifbar waren, im frühen Internet, Apa-Net irgendwie zum Laufen gebracht. Das Ding ist ihm dann etwas entgelitten. Er hat sich dann einfach so massiv verbreitet und irgendwie Systemlast auf den Maschinen erzeugt. Auch eine Situation, mit der Systemadministratoren damals noch nicht so vertraut waren. De facto mussten sie alle ihre Maschinen einmal ausschalten, neu booten und so weiter, um dieses Ding irgendwie herzuwerden. Haben sich natürlich alle großruh aufgeregt und das ist dann auch irgendwie eine weitere Geburtsstunde der Massenpanik, irgendwie was dieses Thema betrifft. Heutzutage haben wir halt Programme, die sich sowohl die klassische Virenmethode, also irgendwie ich lauere, ich werde durch irgendetwas aktiv, also man lädt sich zum Beispiel ein Programm oder man legt eine Diskette ein, wo ein Programm schon mit einem Virus infiziert ist, startet das Programm, dadurch wird der Virus aktiv, lauert rum, jedes andere Programm, was auch noch gestartet wird oder von dem Betriebssystem in irgendeiner Form geöffnet oder geschrieben oder sonst wie angefasst wird, wird eben auch gleich dann noch mit diesem viralen Programm irgendwie versorgt, sodass es das halt von Start zu Start vom Programm immer wieder weiter verbreitet und einfach da so sitzt und lauert. Und moderne Viren, wie wir sie heute eben kennen, oder Würmer, verbreiten sich aber genauso gut eben auch unter Zuhilfenahme des Netzes. Also verbinden sozusagen die Tätigkeit eines Worms mit dem Virus. Und alles irgendwie total dramatisch.
Hier ist das Chaos Radio 63. Wir kommen gleich wieder. In der Nacht gering bewölkt oder klar, die Temperaturen sinken auf 13 bis 9 Grad. Morgen dann wieder sonnig bei Höchstwerten zwischen 26 und 30 Grad. Wir haben jetzt die Meldung mit Falz-Zinke.
Die Castortransporte aus fünf deutschen Atomkraftwerken haben am Abend die französische Grenze erreicht. Die größere Behinderungen gab es nicht. Ziel sind die Wiederaufbereitungsanlagen im französischen Laak und im britischen Sellafield. Bei den Friedensgesprächen zwischen den mazedonischen Konfliktparteien ist offenbar ein Durchbruch erzielt worden. Wie die internationalen Vermittler mitteilten, konnten beide Seiten ihren Streit um Albanisch als zweite Amtssprache beilegen. Einzelheiten wurden jedoch nicht bekannt. Die polnische Armee hat einen 50 Meter breiten Durchlass in einem Deichabschnitt der Weichsel gesprengt. Damit soll die Überflutung weiterer Ortschaften verhindert werden. Die Behörden sprachen von einer leichten Entspannung der Situation. Das italienische Parlament wird den umstrittenen Polizeieinsatz beim G8-Gipfel in Genoa untersuchen. Gleichzeitig stellte sich die Mitte-Rechtskoalition von Ministerpräsident Berlusconi hinter ihren Innenminister Scaiola. Eine deutliche Mehrheit lehnte im Senat einen Misstrauensantrag der Opposition ab. Israel will an der gezielten Tötung von mutmaßlichen Gewalttätern festhalten. Bei einem Raketenangriff waren in Nablus sechs Mitglieder der radikalen Hammers und zwei unbeteiligte Kinder getötet worden. 100.000 Palästinenser nahmen an dem Trauerzug für die Opferthei. Zum Sport im Halbfinale-Rückspiel des Fußball-Ui-Cups fändten sich Wolfsburg und Tourier 2 zu 2. Damit haben die Franzosen das Finale erreicht.
Falk, wir haben uns jetzt so lange nicht gesehen. Bisschen Verkehr? Scheißdreck.
Den ganzen Tag.
Hier ist Chaos Radio 63. Wir reden über Viren im Studio.
Ohne Internet, der Chaos Computer Club ist offline.
Ja, lach du mal.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nicht lachen.
Ich kann dir doch einen Witz tasten drücken.
Okay, ich werf ein 5er ins Phrasenschwein dann, okay? Tim Martin, Chris und Lisa im Studio. Die Klöpfe drückt Holger Klein. Schönen guten Abend, wir reden über Viren. Fragt ihr bitte an, wo waren wir denn stehen geblieben?
Na, wir waren so bei ihm.
Achso, wo es angefangen hat sich zu verbreiten, das.
Dass man nicht definieren kann, was so ein Virus und ein Wurm ist.
Na ja, man kann es definieren, aber es greift halt nicht immer. Ist eigentlich auch nicht so wichtig. Tatsache ist, es gibt die Dinger und alle reden da drüber. Wenn alle drüber reden, dann ist es auf jeden Fall schon mal richtig, oder? Hast du schon mal einen gehabt, Holger?
Äh, ja, ich hatte sogar schon mal einen Trojaner.
Was ist denn schon einer?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Was ist denn ein Trojaner?
Ich weiß es nicht, weil ich nachdem der, also nachdem der, der die andere Seite, also der der mit den, oder der zumindest den passenden Klein dazu hatte, nachdem der auf einer Platte rumgevorwerkte hatte, konnte ich die Kiste nicht mehr booten. Also von da, ich hab dann einfach irgendwie Windows 95 CD reingestopft und neu installiert. Sowas, genau.
Hm, du hast sozusagen die Hintertür, die Hinteröffnung offen gehabt.
Ja, Windows 95 war das damals noch.
Ja, und hat dich dann einer schön fern bedient?
Ja, also er hat offensichtlich irgendwas gelöscht, dass ich die Kiste wirklich nicht mehr hochgefahren gekriegt habe. Was nicht schlimm war, weil ich habe dann auf meinem Mac die wirklich relevanten Sachen drauf gehabt. Und das Ding hab ich nur benutzt, um irgendwie blöd im Internet zu surfen, weil da der große Monitor dran hängen kann. Also ich hab mal, warte mal, was fand das? Auf dem OS 7.6.1 hat mal jemand einen Portscan bei mir gemacht, absichtlich, also nach Ansage, und meinte, käme irgendwie leider jetzt nicht rein. Und das fand ich irgendwie ganz spaßig. Ich weiß nicht, ob es nicht doch was gegeben hätte, aber er hat es nicht gefunden. Und das war also so die Abteilung Skriptkiddy.
Naja, also vielleicht blicken wir nochmal irgendwie so auf die aktuelle Entwicklung. Also es gibt ja nicht nur einen Virus, der irgendwie in letzter Zeit in Diskussion stand, sondern es waren irgendwie mehrere. Ich denke so der totale Virus-Craze ist irgendwie losgegangen mit dem I love you Virus, der halt...
Es war auch ein halben Spaß einfach Mails zu verschicken, wo der I love you ins Subject geschrieben ist.
War nicht cool.
Was hat dann funktioniert?
Dass alle nochmal durchgedreht sind? Sicher.
Und auch hier im Haus, wenn ihr hier im Haus eine I love you Mail verschickt, das kam irgendwann früher oder später. Hier, ich hab ihn, ich hab ihn.
Und keiner wollte dich mehr lieb haben.
Na, weiß ja keiner, dass ich's war.
Keiner wollte von dir mehr lieb gehabt werden. Ja, was war der I love you Virus? Das war halt auch so ein E-Mail-Virus.
Ja, ein E-Mail-Virus. So mit einer, sag ich mal, den ersten E-Mail-Viren, die scriptbasiert waren. Wo halt Leute ausgenutzt haben, dass die Script-Technologien unter Windows relativ leistungsfähig sind. Dass man damit also relativ viel Unsinn anstellen kann. Abgesehen davon war der I love you Virus ja auch interessant. Weil er ja, sag ich mal, auch in gewisser Weise die niederen Instinkte der Menschen angesprochen hat. Sprich, I love you Mail verschickt. Jeder klickt erst mal rauf. Hofft, dass er einen netten Liebesbrief bekommen hat. Und dass sich da viele sozusagen haben, übermannen lassen von dem Topic.
Genau, wer will denn nicht geliebt werden? So, das ist überhaupt so ein... In der Kultur kann man ja dann auch gleich nochmal kommen, was ja eigentlich die Viren so erfolgreich machen.
Hast du da eine Theorie oder mehrere?
Also mindestens eine will ich sagen.
Ich hab da eine Theorie.
Every day there's something new.
Du hast also eine Theorie, hast du eben gesagt, also eine Theorie, warum sich Viren überhaupt verbreiten können.
Na ja, es ist ziemlich auffällig, dass besonders die Viren irgendwie eine besondere Verbreitung erfahren, die halt sagen wir mal einen besonderen niederen Instinkt ansprechen. Also eine E-Mail, die sozusagen ein Attachment hat, was anakurnikova.jpg.vbs heißt, wird halt einfach als anakurnikova.jpg aufgefasst und da hat halt so jeder seine eigenen Vorstellungen, was sich dahinter wohl verbergen mag und offensichtlich möchte das auch jeder wissen. Dass halt natürlich.jpg.vbs nicht das gleiche ist wie.jpg, das ist natürlich eine andere Geschichte, aber das weiß natürlich an der Stelle auch erstmal keiner, deswegen trappt halt jeder in die Falle rein.
Ja, aber ich mein, wenn ich nur den web.de Internetführerschein mache, also das ist so eine CD, die kannst du da kostenlos bestellen, total klasse, weil mein Vater hat sich nachdem er sich hat pensionieren lassen einen Computer gekauft und wollte jetzt mal Internet machen und hat dann irgendwie alle halbe Stunde bei mir angerufen, ich wäre fast wahnsinnig geworden, da hab ich ihm diesen Führerschein geschenkt und selbst der hat's begriffen. Also weil da steht dann alles, was so Otto Normal User zum Thema Sicherheit wissen sollte, steht da drin.
Gut.
Ja und mein Vater ist 65.
Ist auch gut.
Und warum verbreitet sich trotzdem?
Das mag er ja verstanden haben, aber ob er sich daran erinnert, wenn er ein Attachment bekommt...
Ey willst du sagen mein Vater ist doof oder was?
in dem Anakornikopper drinsteht. Nee, das hat ja nichts mit doof zu tun. Da kann man sich bloß nicht so sicher sein, ob die Leute sich dann im entsprechenden Augenblick noch dran erinnern oder ob sie im Affekt dann doch doppelklicken.
Dazu kommt ja noch, dass Windows dieses fancy Feature hat, dass nur die erste Dateiendung als Icon darstellt und den Rest dann hinten runterfallen lässt, sodass die User gar nicht sehen, dass da noch ein VBS hinten dran steht in der default Einstellung.
Das stimmt aber nur bedingt, weil in den E-Mail-Programmen, da zeigen sie schon an, immer die komplette Endung.
Richtet sich das nicht? Ja, aber da steht ein Icon, aber wenn da ein Icon davor steht, dann guckt keiner mehr auf den Dateiennamen. Aber wenn da ein JPEG-Icon ist, dann klickst du aufs JPEG-Icon.
Ne, das Icon ist ja dann auch entsprechend ein VBS-Icon. Oder gar kein Icon. VBS kann man erstmal ganz allgemein sagen. Das ist Visual Basic Script. Das ist eine Skript-Erweitung des Windows-Betriebssystems. Das heißt, ähnlich wie es auf den Unix-Systemen Perl-Interpreter gibt oder beliebige Interpreter für alle möglichen Programmiersprachen gibt es auf den Windows-Hosts. Zum Beispiel VBS für Visual Basic Scripts oder man kann auch JavaScripts ausführen. Und der Scripting-Host interpretiert diese halt. Und diese Skripte ist auch relativ leistungsfähig. Damit kann man also eine ganze Menge Sinnvolles machen, aber natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Unsinn machen.
Und was macht zum Beispiel Anna Kornikova?
Anna Kornikova... Ja, das weiß ich jetzt leider nicht ganz ungenau. Also ich kenne die, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine zerstörende Routine hat. Hat keine. Auf jeden Fall der Verbreitungsmechanismus, der ist klassisch, das heißt, der Anna Kornikova-Virus kann über die Mapi-Schnittstelle von Windows auf das Adressbuch des Benutzers zugreifen, zieht sich da die Adressen raus und verbreitet und verschickt dann auch über die Mapi-Schnittstelle Emails an Adressen aus diesem Adressbuch und verbreitet sich so weiter.
Ich gespannt ihr da sehen könnt. Chaosradio 63, wir reden über Viren. Anna Konikova ist ja vergleichsweise alt, also jetzt der Virus. Also jetzt nicht Anna Konikova, die ist ja vergleichsweise jung, hauptfahrend die ganzen alten Säcke mit den, also die ganzen alten Outlook Loser, die fahren ja ganz gut drauf ab. Im Moment treibt Code Red sich um, hatten wir eben auch schon mal. Also diese Finte vom FBI da, von dieser drei Buchstabenorganisation. Was macht der? Also weil da haben sie ja, ich mein wenn die US-Bundespolizei eine Warnung rausgibt, dann sind die entweder komplett hysterisch geworden oder ist es wirklich was dran, oder?
Es ist schon etwas dran an der Story. Der Punkt ist einfach, dass der Code Red einen Exploit ausnutzt, der sag ich mal für Viren und Wurmverhältnisse noch relativ neu ist. Viele Viren und Würmer nutzen Exploit, sie sind ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre alt. Der Code Red nutzt aber einen Exploit, der ist erst, als er rausgekommen ist, war er erst ungefähr einen Monat alt.
Exploit für unbedarfe Menschen wie mich?
Exploit, eine Sicherheitslücke, die man ausnutzen kann. Er nutzt also wie gesagt einen relativ jungen, sprich jetzt einen Monat alt, mit der Folge, dass viele Systeme, obwohl es einen Patch gibt, noch nicht gepatcht waren. Da ist nur halt eine gewisse Nachlässigkeit von vielen Administratoren, das Thema Sicherheit, nicht ernst genug nehmen. Und diesen Exploit nutzt er halt aus. Ist ein sogenannter Buffer Overflow. Das heißt, der Wurm nutzt einen Puffer aus, den man überschreiben kann und mit der Folge, dass er einen Code zur Ausführung bringen kann, den er selbst liefert, den man aber eigentlich nicht ausführen will, weil es ein bösartiger Code ist.
Und was macht er?
Ja, ja, das ist bekannt. Der wurde von EI analysiert, der Code Red. Und der hat an sich keine Chartroutine. Das ist also ähnlich wie den Skriptvirus, den wir vorhin besprochen hatten. Also er zerstört zumindest keine Dateien. Das was er macht, ist auf englischsprachigen Systemen, die Webseiten, die abgerufen werden, verändern. Da steht dann Hack by Chinese drauf und weiterhin machen tut er, sprich, er breitet sich weiter, greift also andere ARS-Systeme an, guckt ob die auch den gleichen Exploit haben, die gleiche Exploit-Möglichkeit, sie vorhand nutzt er die aus. Und dann hat er noch eine DOS, Denial of Service Routine drin. jedes Monatswörter, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, greift er Whitehouse.Gaff an. Das heißt, er versucht nicht da irgendwie sich Zugriff zu erlangen oder ähnliches, sondern er versucht halt eine Denial of Service Attack. Die aber nicht erfolgreich war, weil der Wurm etwas fehlerhaft konstruiert war. Der versucht Daten an Whitehouse.Gaff zu senden, eine fest eingebaute IP. Die Administratoren von Whitehouse.Gaff haben aber die IP geändert. Und der Wurm wartet auch auf eine Rückantwort von Whitehouse.Gaff.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Genau, genau. Und da die nicht kommt, ist halt nicht so erfolgreich wie geplant.
Aber wer programmiert denn dann so ein Blödsinn? Ich meine, wenn ich schon Whitehouse, also den Server vom Weißen Haus in den USA Alarm legen will, dann programmiere ich das so sauber. Oder können die Chinesen das nicht?
Ich finde es sauber zu tun. Man hätte einfach DNS benutzen können und halt dann mal zu dem Namen Whitehouse.Gaff, die aktuelle IP-Adresse abrufen, aber damit ist man halt immer von diesem DNS abhängig und deshalb hat es durchaus möglicherweise auch seinen grundstatischen IP-Adressen einzufangen.
Ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen auffällig, wenn man DNS-Anfragen durchs Netz schickt.
Und da fordert es natürlich auch wieder mehr Codes, die man über ein Buffer-Overflow transportieren muss. Da kann man nicht beliebige Mengen transportieren, man muss das also schon relativ kompakt halten. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch ein Grund dafür gewesen sein.
Es ist halt auch generell die Frage, was eigentlich nun tatsächlich die Motivation des Programmierers gewesen ist. Es kann auch genauso gut sein, dass er das eben bewusst herausgelassen hat, wohl wissend, dass das durchaus abschaltbar ist. Damit hat er zumindest etwas in die Welt gesetzt, was an einer bestimmten Stelle abschaltbar ist und eben nicht so viel Terror erzeugt, wie das vielleicht möglich wäre. Man kann ja nicht unbedingt auch jedem Viren-Programmierer jetzt immer sofort terroristische Züge unterstellen. Uns ist die Motivation des einzelnen Viren-Programmierers auch immer ein wenig schleierhaft. Ja gut, aber einen zu schreiben, das ist sozusagen die eine Herausforderung, aber ihn dann auch konkret in die Welt zu setzen, das ist irgendwie die andere Sache.
Ich hab immer das Problem, ich denk mir immer, eigentlich richten Nerds keinen Schaden an. Das ist so die Erfahrung, die ich gemacht hab, auch früher in der Schule schon. Also die, die wirklich sowas schreiben konnten, das waren eigentlich immer die freundlicheren Menschen. Die sind zwar mal schlecht behandelt worden, weil irgendwie niemand verstand hat, was sie machen, aber es waren freundlichere Menschen und darum verstehe ich eigentlich nicht, wer das schreibt.
Ja, manchmal wollen Virenautoren auch einfach ihre Liebesbotschaften in die Welt rausstreuen.
Oder auch ihre Hassbotschaften.
Es gab auch schon früher DOS-Zeiten, wo in den Viren irgendwelche Zeichenketten versteckt waren, wo dann drin steht, ich liebe dich.
Tralala, Tralala, das ist die psychose. Ja Holger ich liebe dich.
Also welcher Nerd bläst sich so mit Ecstasy voll, dass er die ganze Welt liebt und so ein Ding programmiert, was möglichst viele Rechner dazu bringt, ich liebe dich aus dem Bildschirm zu schreiben.
Na bei den Viren, die es früher unter DOS gab, waren es mehr bestimmte Liebesnachrichten, also wo halt irgendein Virenprogrammierer die Frau des Lebens gefunden hat und genau das auf dem öffentlichen Wege bekannt geben wollte. Das hat echt nichts zu tun. Jaja, das sagen sie alle. Schüler, gerne diese ganzen spannenden Virenhandbücher gelesen, wo Viren beschrieben waren, wie sie ein bisschen funktionieren, nicht sehr technisch, aber wo es halt schon ein bisschen beleuchtet wurde. Ich meine, Viren waren auch ein richtig großer Mythos.
Bei einem FBI eine Dame, die sich mit der Psychologie von Virenprogramm Viren beschäftigt, also die sich mit denen, wenn sie gefunden werden, unterhält. Nein, die heißt anders, ich habe ihren Namen aber vergessen. Ja genau, Sarah Gordon. Und die meinte halt, dass bei dem, das häufig das Motiv ist, na mal ausprobieren. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen ein Machtgefühl, ne? Wenn man halt so ein Virus geschrieben hat, will man den erstmal ausprobieren.
Und wenn dann halt irgendwie das Internet platt macht, sozusagen, dann fühlt man sich erstmal großartig, bevor man wirklich drüber nachgedacht hat, was das eigentlich für konkrete Auswirkungen hat.
Und sowas bei Code Red, hacked by Chinese, was ist das? Also ich mein, wenn ich die Chinesen wäre, dann würde ich dann teufelnd unter reinschreiben, dass ich das war. Also das ist doch, kannst du daran fühlen, oder?
Na ja, es kann halt verschiedene Motivationen geben. Also entweder er ist Chinese und er möchte gerne, dass alle vor den Chinesen zittern, weil jetzt kommen die Chinesen und wir haben auch Internet. Und ihr würden Amerikaner irgendwie, ihr seid alle ein bisschen doof. Das nachvollziehbare Argumente. Kann aber genauso gut sein, dass es halt ein Amerikaner ist, der irgendwie eigentlich eher darauf aus ist, sein Sicherheitsetat für irgendwie seine Militärabteilung zu sichern. Und der dann natürlich ein Interesse daran hat, dass in der Öffentlichkeit berichtet wird, dass jetzt die Chinesen kommen, die gelbe Gefahr irgendwie. Ja, jetzt auch auf dem Internet. Und wir müssen da halt was gegen tun.
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass ein Ami ist, der total albern ist, und findet diesen von den Medien praktisch hergestellten Hackerkrieg, den es wahrscheinlich nicht mal gibt. Und der sich dann dachte, hey, wenn die schon so viel erzählen, dann mach ich ihnen jetzt halt einen.
Du meinst den Information Warfare?
Genau, dann kriegt ihr jetzt einen Information Warfare.
Na ja, da gibt es eine Menge Leute, die durchaus ein Interesse daran haben, dass darüber diskutiert wird. Das hatten wir auch schon irgendwie in den 80er Jahren, als die ersten Hacks rauskamen. Der NASA Hack, natürlich jetzt auch vom Club die ganzen Sachen. Wir haben natürlich eine breite Medienwelle in Bewegung gesetzt. Und selbstverständlich fingen sie dann alle an zu schreien, ja, jetzt brauchen wir aber auch die entsprechenden Mittel dagegen vorzugeben. Weil wo eine Bedrohung, da müssen wir uns irgendwie schützen. Und das natürlich Pfunde, die sich bestimmte Leute auch sichern wollen. Da gibt es einige Leute, die früher laut geschrien haben, die halt dann in den nächsten 20 Jahren eben davon auch gelebt haben, dass sie geschrien haben. Das ist relativ günstig.
Das ist Chaos Radio 63 und wir reden gleich weiter über Viren. Nach der Musik wollte ich eigentlich so in etwa jetzt behaupten, Tim? Tim, ist das deine Festplatte, die da kaputt ist? Dann hätte es ja sein können, dass ich dir die Schuld in die Schuhe schiebe.
Nein, nein, mein Computer funktioniert jetzt zuverlässig.
Verdammt.
Das war auch ein bisschen gelogen, aber...
Klingt ja kein.
Gibt es da eigentlich Viren für?
Nicht dass ich wüsste, aber es gibt schon Virenscanner. Also naja, es gibt halt die Viren, die Viren... Redest jetzt von MechOS 10, ne? Natürlich. Na ja, es gibt natürlich auch auf dem Macintosh Viren. Lustigerweise gibt es eigentlich meiner Erfahrung nach, das ist immer auch in der persönlichen Erfahrungssicht, gibt es relativ wenig Probleme mit Viren. Es gibt Viren, es gibt auch Viren... genauso wie das MechOS eigentlich recht virenfreundlich ist, also es bietet genug Hux, um sich irgendwie überall rein zu hängen, wo irgendwas bös ist, gibt es eigentlich real relativ wenig Auswirkungen. Da kann man natürlich jetzt darüber mutmaßen, woran das liegt. Es könnte daran liegen, dass einfach nicht so viele Leute Interesse daran haben, auf Mechintosh-Systemen konkret Schaden anzurichten, warum auch immer. Es könnte auch bedeuten, dass diese Virenscanner, die es halt auf dem Markt gibt, würde ich auch noch mal was sagen sollten, durchaus auch ihren Dienst leisten. Ich persönlich hatte durchaus auch schon mal Stress mit Viren, komischerweise fast immer mit dem selben, was ein uralter Virus ist, irgendwie MD, BF, A, Lung hat irgendwie überall rum, hängt sich so ein bisschen rein, macht nicht wirklich so große Probleme, ist relativ leicht entfernenbar und taucht immer mal wieder auf. Dann gab es mal eine Zeit lang einen Virus, der bekannt geworden ist unter dem Namen Autostartworm. Das war ein Virus, der sich ziemlich häufig bei Multimedia-Fabriken auf CD-Roms geschlichen hat und der eine Schwäche des OS ausnutze, also sagen wir mal ein Feature ausnutze, dass er nämlich irgendwie die Möglichkeit bietet, eine eingeschobene CD auch sofort ein bestimmtes Programm zu starten. Das ist bei Mac OS standardmäßig so eingeschaltet, das ist natürlich ein großer Fehler ist. Und dann hat er sich halt automatisch aktiviert und ein bisschen böse Streiche gemacht. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was er gemacht hat, aber war schon ein richtiges Problem. Habe ich aber auch nie gesehen. Und dann gibt es halt mittlerweile auch so ein bisschen den Ärger von Windows mit den Word-Makroviren, weil halt auch Word unter Mac OS benutzt wird, dort die gleiche Möglichkeit bietet. Also die in Word selbst eingebaute Makroscriptsprache, die dann irgendwie den Skripten irgendwie Möglichkeit gibt, auf das eine oder andere Zugriff zu bieten. Man kann auch, denke ich, mit Fug und Recht behaupten, Virenprobleme in den letzten Jahren waren vor allem Microsoft-Probleme.
It's all about the wildness, the undeserted desert, undeserted desert and its bright nights, falling stars and homes.
To me. To me.
To me.
Du sagtest Tim?
Du sagtest Tim. Du sagtest Tim. Du sagtest, wir wollen darüber reden, was diese Virenscan-Programme taugen.
Ja, ich meine es gibt da ja so einiges. So, es gibt vor allem verschiedene Kategorien von dieser Software. Kennt sicherlich jeder irgendwie das ein oder andere Tool. Ein oder andere hat es drauf, Norton, Anti-Virus.
Zumindest die klassische Version, die Client basierte, sprich auf dem Client installierte Rechner, die sind ja doch recht weit verbreitet. Sollte man heutzutage unbedingt auch haben. Vor allem wenn man viel im Internet rumtreibt, viel runterlädt, kann das nicht schaden. Bisschen interessanter und nur in mittleren und größeren Firmen verbreitet, sind die Versionen, die Virenscanner, die auch gleich Mails und Traffic aus dem Internet nach Viren scannen und die entfernen. Was an sich eine gute Sache ist, was manchmal in die falsche Richtung geht, dass es gleich mit Content Scanning kombiniert wird, dass also das Internet auf die Weise zensiert wird. Ansonsten und an sich war eine interessante Sache.
Also naja, es ist schon, es ist natürlich schon discussionswürdig irgendwie, inwieweit diese Dinger halt die Sicherheit auch nur vorgaukeln, weil die gehen halt schon auch etwas dramatisch vor. Beispielsweise I love you, da gibt es eigentlich relativ wenig, also jeder Virenscanner hat seine eigene Methode, wie er das Ding macht, hier angreift und erkennt halt tatsächlich dieses böse Attachment. Andere Systeme gingen einfach mal so dramatisch vor, dass sie einfach mal jede Mail, wo I love you drin ist, statt einfach rausgefiltert haben. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass Leute auf einmal auf Mailing-Listen, wo darüber diskutiert wurde, was man dagegen tun kann, auf einmal keine Mail mehr bekommen haben, weil könnte ja böse sein. Und es gibt jetzt halt auch schon so eine aufkeimende Industrie. Man kann sich irgendwie Internet auch irgendwie schon in Viren freikaufen. Nur, dass das natürlich auch stark diskussionswürdig ist, inwieweit das A funktioniert, also was für ein System vertraue ich denn da eigentlich. So, es greift halt aktiv in meinen Content ein. Dieses Content-Scanning wird ohnehin schon gemacht. Also alle Service-Provider kaufen sich in zunehmendem Maße Software, die halt nicht nur Accounting macht, also die jetzt irgendwie berechnet, wie viel ist hin und her gegangen, sondern die auch ganz klar mitliest, wie viel Mails gehen dahin, was steht drin in den Mails, welche Worte werden benutzt. Die suchen nach Passwords, die suchen nach allem Möglichen, die versuchen halt das Verhalten irgendwie von allen möglichst transparent mit irgendwelchen Statistiken darzulegen und darauf irgendwelche neuen Marketing-Modelle aufzubauen oder sonst wie Schnarfs.
Und was ist von diesen Desktop-Firewalls zu halten?
Das hängt sicherlich vom einzelnen Produkt ab. Generell Unix-Betriebssysteme haben ohnehin heutzutage Firewall-Funktionalität schon mit eingebaut. Meistens schaltet das dann halt einfach nur frei oder macht es irgendwie leichter benutzbar.
Wobei die meisten ja dann doch irgendwie Windows 98 benutzen müssen.
Ja, wie sieht das bei Windows aus?
Bei Windows 98 oder auch bei 2000 sowas nicht eingebaut, aber die Nachrüst-Versionen, die man natürlich gegen Geld kaufen muss, die sind recht beliebt.
Also so Zeug wie AdGuard oder sowas in der Richtung?
So in die Richtung. Da gibt es eine ganze Latte von Programmen. Auch viele, die wirklich unbrauchbar sind, wo man sich dann ärgert, die eigentlich gar nichts helfen.
Du darfst gerne sagen, welche das sind, wenn du das weißt.
Mach ich jetzt nicht. Will dann niemand diskriminieren.
Mach mal.
Mach ruhig mal.
Was ist denn zum Beispiel scheiße?
Oder sag was gut ist.
Ich muss gestehen, mir fällt der Name jetzt nicht ein.
Dann denk nochmal drüber nach. Also ich meine, es gibt halt irgendwie so jetzt unter UNIX zum Beispiel, das gilt ja jetzt auch für Mac OS X, gibt es halt so die in den TCP IP Stack, also in das Standard-Triebsystem TCP IP Behandlung eingebaute Möglichkeit, eingehende Pakete nach bestimmten Kriterien schlicht ergreifend zu sperren. Also jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn man mal das Code Red nimmt. Code Red ist ja ein Angriff von außen, das heißt über das Netz versucht sich jemand auf meinen Server zu machen. In diesem Fall ist es halt der Microsoft IES Web Server, der auch bei Windows 98 nicht dabei ist und bei anderen Systemen vielleicht auch nicht. Eigentlich bei 2000, die vollmäßig eingeschaltet?
Beim Server ja, bei der Client Version nicht.
Gut, aber jeder, der immer eingeschaltet hatte, den Laufen, dann weiß das vielleicht auch nicht mehr. Und diese Software versucht sich dann über den Standard Port, also die Adresse sozusagen auf den Rechner, an dieses Programm zu wenden. So und jetzt kann halt eine Firewall hergehen und sagen, okay, ihr geht jetzt mal nix rein. Dann ist natürlich die Funktionalität der Software erstmal ausgehebelt, aber im Idealfall hat man halt eine brauchbare GUI, die an das irgendwie klarmacht, dass das jetzt ausgeschaltet ist und dass man das eben auch einschalten kann, wenn man es wirklich haben will.
Ist dir jetzt eingefallen, welche Firewall man nicht nehmen sollte?
Den Namen ist mir leider immer noch nicht eingefallen. Was ich noch sagen kann, solche einfachen Paketfelter Funktionalität, die gibt es zumindest unter Windows 2000 Server auch. Die ist auch fest eingebaut. Was vielleicht den Endnutzer, der normalerweise nur seinen Office benutzt interessieren wird, dass in der nächsten Version von Windows im XP auch so eine einfache und auch für normale User zu bedienende Personal Firewall drin sein wird, die den größten Teil der serverbasierten Zugriff auf den Rechner ablocken wird.
Chaosradio 63 auf 40, wir reden über Viren. Tim, du hast eben gesagt, Microsoft ist da ja besonders beliebt bei Virenprogrammierern. Liegt das an der Verbreitung oder liegt es tatsächlich daran, dass es einfach mehr Angriffsflächen bietet?
Sowohl als auch. Einerseits ist natürlich vollkommen klar, dass ein System, das weiter verbreitet ist, auch mehr attackiert wird, weil es auch von mehr Leuten bekannt ist, mehr Leute darauf rumspielen, vollkommen klar wäre irgendwie.
Und was natürlich demokratieber ist, auf einen Betriebssystem aufzusetzen, das weit verbreitet ist, als wenn man ein Virus schreibt, der dann sofort verrückt, weil er keine Systeme findet.
Natürlich gibt es natürlich auch mehr Programmierer für die Windows-Plattform. So ist das Potenzial einfach größer an Leuten, die Virus beschreiben können.
Aber ist es ein unsichereres Betriebssystem als die anderen?
Es ist für Endkunden.
Na, es ist halt, man muss schon unterscheiden zwischen irgendwie den klassischen Desktop-Systemen und den Multi-User-Systemen. Und bei Desktop-Systemen gibt es eigentlich de facto nur zwei. Da gibt es halt irgendwie den Mac und dann gibt es Windows. Und Unix schickt sich zwar an, insbesondere Linux auch in diesem Bereich vorzudringen, aber das ist weder der Fall noch wird das irgendwie schon morgen soweit sein. Das alte Windows, die 3.11.95 und so weiter, halten halt darüber hinaus auch keine Unterscheidung zwischen mehreren Benutzern. Das heißt, wenn ein Programm erst mal auf dem System aktiv ist, kann es dann auch sofort alles tun. Es kann auf jede Hardware zugreifen, es hat einfach beliebigen Freiraum, sich irgendwie maximal negativ oder positiv zu entfalten. Und das ist halt bei Unix, also bei Multi-User-Systemen, eben auch so erst mal nicht gegeben. Da hat man dann sozusagen, wenn das Programm aktiv ist, zumindest noch den Schutz, den das Betriebssystem auch seinen eigenen Programm gegenüber bietet, beziehungsweise das Misstrauen, was das Betriebssystem den eigenen Programm gegenüber zeigt. Und gut, sowohl kommt Unix jetzt auf den Desktop, zumindest auf dem Mac, eben dann auch bei Linux, als auch hat Windows in den neueren Versionen Multi-User-Fähigkeiten und entsprechende Protection. Das wird schon helfen. Ich habe vor allem deshalb gesagt, dass es ein Microsoft-Problem ist, weil einer der größten Schwachstellen in der letzten Zeit war vor allem Outlook. Die Leute benutzen diese Software, diese Mail-Software von Microsoft, und sie bot eben relativ einfach am Anfang die Möglichkeit, eine Mail hinzuschicken mit einem Attachment. Man klickt da halt drauf und dann wird es gestartet. Und dazu kommt eben auch noch, dass Microsoft in dieses Betriebssystem und in diese Programme eine sehr allgemeine API reingebaut hat, dass man eben dann auch gleich auch andere Programme, Application Programmers Interface, also wogegen man programmiert als Programmierer. Also Möglichkeiten bietet eben auch gleich noch andere Programme fernzusteuern, Adressbücher auszulesen. Ja, zum Beispiel bei Actrix war das ja auch irgendwie so ein Thema, da konnte man irgendwie sogar eine Webseite aktiven Code einfangen, die ja dann irgendwie mal eben angefangen hat, das Quicken irgendwie loszuschicken und irgendwie eine Banküberweisung einzutragen, die das nächste Mal dann automatisch ausgeführt wird. Da hat es gemis alles gezeigt worden. Und gut, Microsoft ist halt mittlerweile auch ein bisschen aufgewacht. Ist ja ganz klar, weil so viele negative Publisite, die kann man sich nicht leisten, aber sie sind halt immer noch dabei, das irgendwie im Wesentlichen als Feature da hinzustellen als irgendwie ein Bug. Was man so vertreten kann, aber was man auch ganz anders sehen kann. Man kann sagen, ich möchte generell erst mal ein sicheres System haben und dann schalte ich mir die Features frei. Und bei Microsoft ist es immer so, jetzt schalten wir erstmal alle Features an und wenn es irgendwo ein Problem gibt, dann kann man es ja vielleicht auch mal ausschalten.
Ich hab noch eine Anmerkung zu... Soll ich lauter sprechen? Bitte.
Ja, ich hab die Musik jetzt leiser, aber jetzt geht's wieder.
Ich hab noch eine Anmerkung zu Tims Multi-User Versus Single-User System. Um mit einem Virus Stress zu machen, reichen aber auch schon die Rechte die normale User in ein Multi-User System hat. Also es ist eigentlich kein größeres Argument. Zum Beispiel der Code Redworm. Ähm, braucht ja auch an sich nicht so viele Rechte, da muss ich halt nicht irgendwo so kunde, nicht vom Stuhl fallen.
Chris, Chris macht ein I-Gesicht.
Ja, ja, das stimmt. Also der Code Red nutzt doch schon recht weitgehende Rechte aus. Er braucht ihn nicht unbedingt, aber für sein Verbreitungssystem und auch wie er sich ins System einisst, nutzt er recht weitgehende Rechte aus. Da benutzt er den sogenannten System Account von Windows 2000 und NT und kann da faktisch alles machen, was das Betriebssystem auch kann. Es ist also schon recht weitgehend von ihm.
Ich meine, vom Prinzip her...
Ja, vom Prinzip her ist das natürlich abzudeichten. Ich meine, wenn er mir meinen Home-Director löscht, ist das für mich ja eigentlich schon der Gau.
Ja, und außerdem, ein Virus würde ja versuchen, sich ins System einzunisten, sodass er beim Neustart auch wieder gestartet wird. Aber dieser Code Red tut das ja nicht, der bleibt ja nur im Speicher und wenn man den Computer rebootet, dann ist er auch weg. Und das könnte er auch schon mit einfachen User-Rechten machen. Und von da eine DOS-Attacke fahren, das ja auch schon kritisch war.
Ich hab ja auch nur gesagt, es schränkt halt auch ein, klar. Also hat man auch erstmal irgendwie in seinem eigenen User-Pist.
Ja klar, aber so um Schaden anzurichten, reicht auch normale User-Rechte von uns.
Also im günstigsten Fall ist er nicht in der Lage, das System als solches auch noch vollständig zu zerstören. Das heißt, selbst wenn man keine Daten mehr hat, hat man zumindest noch ein bootfähiges System. Das mag einen vielleicht nicht besonders erfreut dann, aber... Ich meine, was aber noch dazu kam, und was auch bei Unix eigentlich auch immer noch gilt, ist, Viren nutzen nicht häufig eben auch bestimmte Gegebenheiten aus. Also dass irgendwie bestimmte Dateien an bestimmten Stellen auch immer sind und immer den gleichen Namen haben. Sie nutzen insbesondere bei Windows natürlich die Tatsache aus, dass eben auch alle Programme das gleiche Binary-Format verwenden. Also man weiß einfach, wie Code da ist. Man kann ihn einfach direkt binär einspielen, ohne dass da was übersetzt werden muss. Während halt bei Unix-Architekturen von System zu System große Unterschiede sein können. Sowohl im Fallsystem-Layout, bei der Benahmsung, bei dem verwendeten Unix, ob man einen Linux hat, welche Version, wie man das persönlich sich eingerichtet hat. Oder man hat vielleicht auch einen anderen Prozessor. Wenn man halt auf ein Power-PC fährt, dann schadet einem ein Intel-Binary natürlich überhaupt nicht. Und umgekehrt, das sind halt alles Sachen, die Unix nicht so attraktiv gemacht haben für Viren. Aber umso mehr es verbreitet sein wird, umso mehr Attacken wird es da auch geben.
Gerade durch Linux, auf den Intel-PCs, erfährt die Unix-Welt ja gerade auch eine gewisse Standardisierung. Sodass man da auch befürchten muss, dass Leute das ausnutzen werden und dass es auf der Basis auch mehrere Viren in Zukunft geben wird.
Gibt es da vernünftige Scanner für? Also für den User zu Hause?
Es gibt da verschiedene Lösungen, die im Laufe der Zeit entstanden sind. Also ich glaube, es fing alles an mit diesen einfachen Scannern, die nach bestimmten Zeichenketten innerhalb von Programmen geguckt haben. Und das ist wohl auch damals ein bisschen eine Herausforderung gewesen, weil es gab dann plötzlich eine ganze Reihe von Viren. Und es wurden immer mehr. Mittlerweile gibt es so über 50.000, 60.000.
Da reden wir aber jetzt von Windows, nicht von Unix.
Na, das ist eigentlich noch so in dieser Dos-Phase. Also erst so Anfang der 80er mit den Heimcomputern an und mit den Leuten, die sich dann das Kettenlaufwerk gekauft haben und später festplatten und irgendwann bei den vielen Softwaregetauschen auch mal festgestellt haben, dass sie sich mal einen Virenscanner organisieren sollten. Und die ersten funktionierten, glaube ich, nur auf dieser Zeichenketten-Findenbasis. Und später hat das nicht mehr funktioniert mit den Zeichenketten suchen, weil die Viren-Programmierer da auch einen gewissen Sport drin gesehen haben. Und sie fingen dann an, ihre Viren so zu gestalten, dass sie einfach ihre Formen und ihren Code ändern. Und dann ist das halt hinfällig mit diesen...
Selbstständig ändern?
Ja, die mutieren halt. Und dann mussten die Viren-Software-Hersteller halt was gegen machen und haben dann angefangen, heuristische Suchmethoden zu entwickeln.
Was für?
Also heuristik ist im Prinzip was recht Allgemeines. Es ist keine hundertprozentige Lösung für irgendein Problem, aber es nähert sich halt an einer Problemlösung an. Man kann Viren finden.
Das kapier ich jetzt gerade nicht. Also was ist heuristik?
Na ja, man kann halt nicht irgendwie zielgerade nach einer Methode vorgehen, sondern eben irgendwie erahnen, was dann wohl meistens so hinhaut und danach so klappt es meistens. Und dann machen wir das mal so und dann haben wir auch die meisten Treffer so. Wenn man irgendwie nur nach einer Methode vorgeht, irgendwie nur so das, dann kann das eben gleich in den Lehrer laufen. Aber wenn man halt vorher mal so analysiert, naja, so in etwa könnte es meistens funktionieren.
Ganz praktisch heißt das zum Beispiel, dass die Virenscanner nach bestimmten Aktivitäten gesucht haben, die Viren normalerweise ausführen, sprich nach Code-Segmenten, möglichst kleinen, die sie halt einfach identifizieren können und daran halt ausgemacht haben, dass es ein Virus oder es ist keiner.
Genau, typische Aktion, die Viren machen, sind Interrupt-Vektoren verbiegen, um sich im System einzuklinken oder keine Ahnung, wie ist denn das bei Windows? Zumindest wenn ein Virus versucht, sich in seiner Umgebung einzeln nisten, dann ruft es meistens bestimmte API-Calls auf. Also bei Windows sind das irgendwelche Funktionen, um sich irgendwo zu registrieren, keine Ahnung, wo man das da alles tun kann. Und unter DOS früher waren das halt in erster Linie, sich in die Systemfunktionalität da einklinken. Das war überall Interrupt-Vektoren.
Ben Fritz in Frankfurt oder? Dann 101, 5.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
In der Nacht gering bewölbt oder sogar klar Temperaturen zwischen 13 und 9 Grad morgens sonnig bei Temperaturen von maximal 30 Grad. Die Meldungen mit Falk Zilke.
Die Castotransporte aus fünf deutschen Atomkraftwerken haben am Abend die französische Grenze passiert. Größere Behinderungen gab es nicht. Ziel sind die Wiederaufbereitungsanlagen im französischen La Ague und im britischen Cellafield. Bei den Friedensgesprächen zwischen den mazedonischen Konfliktparteien ist offenbar ein Durchbruch erzielt worden. Wie die internationalen Vermittler mitteilten, konnten beide Seiten ihren Streit um Albanisch als zweite Amtssprache beilegen. Eins Leiten wurden zunächst jedoch nicht bekannt. Das italienische Parlament wird den umstrittenen Polizeieinsatz beim G8-Gipfel in Genua untersuchen. Gleichzeitig stellte sich die Mitterechtskoalition von Ministerpräsident Berlusconi hinter ihren Innenminister Skyola. Eine deutliche Mehrheit lehnte im Senat einen Misstrauensantrag der Opposition ab. Israel will an der gezielten Tötung von mutmaßlichen Gewalttätern festhalten. Bei einem Raketenangriff waren in Nablus sechs Mitglieder der radikalen Hammers und zwei unbeteiligste Kinder getötet worden. 100.000 Palästinenser nahmen an einem Trauerzug für die Opfertei. Zum Sport. Im Halbfinale-Rückspiel des Fußball-Ui-Cups trennten sich Wolfsburg und Trier 2 zu 2. Damit scheidet Wolfsburg aus. Ebenfalls ausgeschieden ist 1860. Die Münchner verloren gegen Newcastle United 1 zu 3.
23.32.
Vielen Dank, Falz.
Pritz präsentiert...
Mittwoch, 19.
September.
Verlegt den Zylodrom.
Ha ha ha. Das ist super.
For great justice, erklär das doch bitte mal, for great justice.
Na ja, es gab da 1989 mal ein Arkadespiel, das hieß Zero Wing. War irgendwie japanisch und ist dann irgendwie etwas mager eingeenglischt worden. Die Übersetzung war so haarsträumend, hat das ja eben so gehört irgendwie.
Was, wir haben ja auch nochmal ein Skript hier. Somebody set up as the bomb.
Es ist so unglaublich irgendwie. Ja genau, wie geht Single? Also man kann das, also wenn man das sieht, ist es einfach irgendwie affig irgendwie. Aber es ist halt so der Kult geworden. Nicht zuletzt durch dieses Video, das wir gerade abgespielt haben, das gibt es halt eigentlich auch als Video, also als Slash-Video. Und irgendwie, das ist ein Megakult irgendwie ausgebrochen. Also wer es nicht kennt, sollte mal bei Google einfach all your base are belong to us eingeben. Da gibt es dann irgendein tonnenweise Homepage mit Links, mit History Timelines, mit Sightings, wo das irgendwie alles gesehen wurde.
Verbreitet sich das etwa viral?
Auf gewisser Hinsicht sicherlich schon. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein netter Explore.
Wir reden über Viren hier im Chaos Radio.
Genau, wir reden irgendwie ein bisschen alleine. Wir wollen jetzt natürlich auch mal irgendwie mit anderen reden. Genau, euch da draußen irgendwie auch mal zur Sprache gucken. Wir würden gerne mal mit Leuten reden, die selber schon mal ein Virus programmiert haben. Ihr dürft auch anonym anrufen.
Genau.
Uns würde da insbesondere die Motivation betreffen. Vielleicht hat auch jemand schon mal mit so einem Virus Construction Set rumgespielt und sich sozusagen seinen Ready-to-run-Virus zusammengeklickt.
Da gibt es natürlich so einen Bausatz dann dafür.
Das gibt es auch. Virus Construction Set und dann kann auch der letzte Idiot irgendwie die gängigen Exploit-Maßnahmen machen, das ist halt so ein bisschen schon die modernere Version des Cryptkiddin irgendwie. Dann werden das auch irgendwann nochmal in bunt in 3D und irgendwie...
Das ist klasse, das ist wie Instant-Kaffee.
Genau.
Ich lass schon mal die Nummer sagen, warte mal.
So, jetzt mal anrufen hier.
0331 für Potsdam.
70.97.110.
Was schätzt man? Gibt es irgendwie Schätzungen, wie viele Virenprogrammierer es gibt?
Die wechseln sich ja auch immer ab.
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Was verdient man eigentlich als Virenprogrammierer?
Wenn man so eine Antiviren-Software angestellt ist, ich meine, das war doch eine dieser Verschwörungstheorien, dass die Antiviren-Software-Hersteller Virenprogrammierer schätzt.
Ich glaub, das find ich gar nicht nötig.
Ob das so eine Verschwörungstheorie ist oder eine Verschwörungspraxis, das ist natürlich eine Frage, die man sich stellen muss. Genau hat man ja im Prinzip schon angesprochen. Es gibt halt eine große Industrie, die davon lebt, dass Leute Angst haben vor Viren. Wenn man sich mal die Top 10 anschaut von Software, die so verkauft wird, da sind diese Systemtools und die Antivirus-Tools recht weit oben vertreten. Das ist nicht unbedingt die Top-Stage, aber da wird schon ordentlich Geld generiert. Zahlen kenn ich jetzt nicht. Insbesondere im Enterprise-Bereich ist das natürlich schon ein wirklich dicker Markt. Das hat man schon allein gesehen. In den letzten zwei Jahren gab es eine extreme Kaufphase, wo große Firmen wie NI und so weiter massenhaft die einzelnen versprengten Virus-Tools, die die einzelnen Firmen hergestellt haben, zusammengekauft haben, um dann eben auch gesamt übergreifend für alle möglichen Betriebssysteme irgendein Produkt angeboten zu haben, um das eben Firmen als Gesamtlösung erstmal zur Verfügung zu stellen und später dann auch integrierte Systeme zu bauen.
Ich vermute, dass in Berlin Brandenburg irgendwie keine Virenprogrammierer leben.
Glaub ich nicht, aber auf jeden Fall wird es ein Systemadministrat von geben, die vielleicht auch schon Probleme konkret mit Viren gehabt haben. Das würde uns natürlich auch interessieren. Wer da schon mal ein Problem hat, oder falls ihr eine besondere Begegnung mit einem Virus der dritten Art.
Dann solltet ihr anrufen und mit uns drüber reden unter 0331 70 97 110 0331 77 97 110 falls ihr mal selber Viren geschrieben habt oder arge Probleme mit Viren gehabt habt. Ja, da würd ich sagen, habt ihr euch ein bisschen weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, weil so ein Thema scheinen Viren gar nicht zu sein. Hat noch nie jemand irgendwie mit zu tun gehabt, keine Erfahrung mit Viren. Also weder drunter gelitten, geschweige denn selbst mal dran programmiert. Sonst könnte sie hier anrufen.
Vielleicht hat uns ja auch gar keiner mit.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Vielleicht sind wir schon komplett, wir fliegen schon wahrscheinlich im Raum, irgendwie eingekapselt in einer Zeitblase.
Drunter gelitten haben sie sicherlich.
Ja, was ist ihnen zu peinlich hier anzurufen und zu sagen, ich hab dann auf Anna Konikofer geklickt?
Es gibt tatsächlich gerade noch einen anderen Virus.
Ich sag mal gerade die Nummer, falls einer doch irgendwie über seinen Schatten bringt. 03317797110 ist die Nummer, wenn man sich hier outen will. Ich habe auf Anna Konikofer geklickt.
Wir toppen dann auch T-Shirts. Ich habe auf Anna Konikofer geklickt.
Das ist gut. Können wir die nicht mal über Interhänden machen?
Schick mir ne Mail.
Aber dass es jemandem peinlich ist, ist gar nicht so unberechtigt, weil dieser Zilkamp-Virus, der gerade auch im Umlauf ist, hat ja das, ich würde sagen Feature, dass er das Handy ausgeht.
Das ist der Feature, das das Handy angeht. Ist das bei dir jetzt ein Bug oder ein Feature, dass du nicht weißt, wo Mikrofone sind?
Dieser Zilkamp-Bomb guckt, nein, das ist ein Virus, und der guckt in den Ordner mit den privaten Dateien und greift da irgendwelche Dokumente raus und schickt die halt durch die Gegend an Leute, der es überhaupt nichts angeht. Also alle Leute, die das jetzt nicht betrifft, weil sie nicht Windows fahren, freuen sich halt immer, weil sie Quartalspläne von irgendwelchen Firmen zugeschickt bekommen oder irgendwelche geheimen Dokumente oder zumindest ja private und deine Sammelwut.
Da muss man schon gar nicht mehr in ihre Wave-Ladensätze einsteigen.
Wo kriege ich den her, der hängt auch an irgendeiner E-Mail als Attachment dran?
Ja, glaube ich auch an Attachment.
Wer schickt denn nach der Sendung alle Viren zu?
Genau, das ist nett.
Kommt halt auch immer die Chaosradio und Ticker. We got signal, kann ich an dieser Stelle sagen. Name Thomas. Du hast mal ein Virus erwischt, also so erwischt und ausgemerzt, oder wie?
Naja, mich hat es einmal beim Ausmerzen erwischt, sagen wir mal so. Und zwar habe ich das Teil noch rechtzeitig erkannt, konnte einige Rechner schützen. Ich habe mit meinem Notebook, mit dem Virenscanner das Ding eliminiert. Aber beim Ausschalten habe ich nicht dran gedacht, dass mein Virus-Scanner im Bootsektor nicht aktiv war. Ich schalte meine Kiste wieder ein und nichts geht mehr. Warning, CMOS Schicksum unveiled, stand da nur noch und spuckte mir hier ein paar Speicherbelegungen aus oder so und dann ist Ende, geht nichts mehr. Unaccepted amount of memory und time date corrupt.
Was hat er denn noch mitgekriegt, wie das Ding hieß?
Ich glaube, das Ding hieß, habe ich mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben, Spirit A oder so ähnlich. Ja, da kam jemand und hat eine Programmgruppe gespielt auf ein paar Rechner, die wir da hatten und der hat das Ding mitgebracht. Nachhinein habe ich das mitgekriegt. Der hatte ein Virusproblem, habe dann die Rechner gecheckt und habe das auch gleich bemerkt, nur wie das Problem war. Meine kleine Buchte hier, die habe ich dabei zerschossen und nur stehe ich da. Muss wahrscheinlich ein Virusupdate machen und weiß nicht genau wie.
Das ist ja dann auch noch das Problem. Biosupdaten, wenn man ein laufendes System hat, das funktioniert ja noch einigermaßen.
Das war auch bei diesem CIH. Ich glaube, der kam aus Taiwan so, dass er halt auch ein paar Rechner unbaubar gemacht hat. Einfach dadurch, weil das mit dem Bios rumschreiben und irgendwie Flashzeug programmieren auch manchmal schief gehen kann. Das Schloss von Aaaaaaaah.
Entschuldige Thomas, es schweift mir ab.
Wenn man nur einen Rechner hat, dann ist das ein echtes Problem. Weil dann muss man zu Leuten fahren, die irgendwie die Möglichkeit haben, irgendwie neues Bios zu toasten oder was auch immer.
Na, ein Virus, der ähnliche Schadroutine oder genau so eine Schadroutine hat oder der zurzeit aktiv ist, ist der Magistrar Virus. Wie gesagt, der hat genau solche Schadroutinen, sprich CMOS überschreiben, Flash überschreiben und ähnliches.
Und was mache ich da? Was macht Thomas? Er geht zum Computerhändler seines Vertrauens.
Richtig, jetzt, wenn es erstmal passiert ist, sprich, wenn der Schaden da ist, dann geht er am besten zum Computerhändler seines Vertrauens oder zum guten Freund, der ihm halt ein Bios-Update, ein Refresh ermöglicht, des Fleschwands.
Kann man da eigentlich auch eine Anzeige erstatten gegen Unbekannt?
Könnte man Juristen anrufen? 031-77-91-0 können wir Anzeige gegen Unbekannt stellen. Thomas, wir hoffen, dass wir dir helfen konnten.
Was hast du denn für ein OS eigentlich? Also was für ein Betriebssystem?
Ich hatte hier DOS als Grundlage und dann hab ich noch Windows 98 drauf gehabt.
Und wie denkst du jetzt über Virenprogrammierer?
Kein Problem damit. Ich meine, das war meine eigene Dummheit. Und deswegen ruft wahrscheinlich auch keiner an.
Super Einstellung.
Alle keinen Mumm. Obwohl mittlerweile haben wir die Leitungen voll. Thomas, danke schön. Und jetzt haben wir den Feind von Thomas hier. Hallo Gregor. Also du hast es schon mal probiert?
Ja, mit meinem Freund aus meiner Gasse. Wir haben uns mal hingesetzt und versucht dann zu programmieren. Aber das war im Endeffekt nachher mit allen Programmen, die man hätte mitschicken müssen, so groß, dass es nicht geklappt hätte.
Ein Gigabyte Attachment.
In welcher Sprache habt ihr denn das versucht?
Ich weiß gar nicht. Ich konnte auch nicht so viel.
Wir waren ganz am Anfang noch. Ich kann selbst auch gar nicht programmieren. Mir kamen Ideen, was wir so gemacht haben, was ich nach 30 Boot Format sehe oder sonst das.
Also du hattest nur die dreckigen Ideen und hast andere die schmutzige Arbeit machen lassen?
War ganz lustig, aber...
Was hätte das denn machen sollen alles?
Ja, es sollte eigentlich nur die Dateien, also bei jedem Start irgendwie ein paar Ordner löschen und nach jedem Start dann auch den Format zählen. Nur zum Spaß halt einfach, also man setzt sich da wirklich hin und denkt, ja was kann man jetzt und lasst mal was machen, ist langweilig.
Aber du hast ihn nie frei gesetzt? Ich meine wäre er nicht in Gigabyte Kurs gewesen, also angenommen du hättest ihn in schlanke 60 Kilobyte reinbekommen, was hättest du dann getan?
Dann hätten wir ihn wahrscheinlich an irgendwelche Leute verschickt, aber, ach, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, also...
Und wie hätte der dafür gesorgt, dass die Leute das Ding auch ausführen?
Wir hätten eine Server-Datei geschickt oder wir hätten es als andere Datei ausgegeben oder sonst was. Also ich bin dafür auch wirklich nicht so der Spezialist. Ich bin zwar gern mit meinem Computer, habe gern mit meinem Computer zu tun, aber Programmieren liegt mir doch noch etwas fern.
Aber ich meine, kannst du irgendwie schildern, was hat dich denn da so gezogen daran? Ich meine, jetzt irgendwie, das ist ja ein gewisses zerstörerisches Element, was man da in den Tag legt, wenn man so eine Software schreibt. Hat dich das nicht gebremst von vornherein?
Nö, also ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht habe ich auch so eine kleine zerstörerische Ader. Aber ich weiß nicht, wir haben einfach aus langer Weile heraus gehandelt. Hatten eigentlich keinen wirklich driftigen Grund.
Das entspricht ja voll dem Klischee, irgendwie der 17-jährige...
16!
Oder 16-jährige. Du hast das auf dem Monitor.
14 ist noch besser, sitzt im Kinderzimmer.
Ich war noch mal zwei Jahre jünger gewesen. Das war eine ziemlich komische Aktion. Aber ich habe auch mal einen Virus bekommen. Ich meine zumindest, einen bekommen zu haben. Das war eine E-Mail, ohne Absender, ohne Texten, ohne Anhangdatei, mit einem Excel-Datei, also recht offensichtlich habe ich das nicht geöffnet.
Auch keinen Virenscanner drüber gejagt, was das sein könnte?
Ne, hab ich gar nicht.
Aber selber schreiben. Gregor, Gregor, Gregor, danke für deinen Anruf. Alles klar. Sei uns eine Warnung für alle anderen Gregors da draußen. Okay. Und noch einer. Hallo Anonymous. Ja, du bist das, genau du, der da guten Morgen gesagt hat. Du hast schon mal mit Viren experimentiert. Also wie weit geht denn Experimentieren eigentlich?
Experimentieren fängt so auf dem heimischen Rechner an und könnte dann natürlich auch noch weitergehen. Also es ging auch noch ein bisschen weiter. Im Schulnetzwerk kursierten dann so einige Versionen, aber ja, das führte dann auch zu disziplinarischen Maßnahmen und dann stellt man das dann freiwillig ein.
Was hat ein Virus gemacht?
Der ist glaube ich, also war eine Co-Produktion mit einem Kumpel zusammen.
Wir haben hier nur die Drahtzieher am Telefon, ich merke das schon.
Nee, da war ich schon selbst mit tätig. Das Problem war halt, dass die Auslöseroutine da leicht defekt war. Und das Ding dann halt einfach so hoch ging, als wir noch vor den Rechnern saßen. Das war nicht so der Bringer.
Hast du noch ein paar technische Details?
In was hast du es geschrieben?
Ja, das war noch die gute alte DOS-Zeit mit 2x-Nachziger-Rechnern und so.
Und was hätte das Teil machen müssen?
Also das Teil hätte eigentlich nur noch 3 Tage warten müssen. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ob das Datum oder eine Anzahl von Boot-Vorgängen war.
Welche zerstörerische Wirkung, meine ich, hat das Ganze?
Es hat bloß die ersten Lektoren an der Festplatte.
Achso, achso, ja, nee, das ist ja nicht schlimm. Die ersten Sektoren, das ist bei alten Compact-Rechnern ein Teil des Bihauses übrigens.
Hast du den jetzt nur geschrieben, um zu sehen, ob er funktioniert? Du hast ihn ja auch ausgesetzt, hast du gesagt. An was für einer Schule? Man muss den Namen jetzt nicht so haben.
Welche arme Sau hat er administriert oder wart ihr selber?
Nee, wir waren natürlich selber. Es waren natürlich die Leute, die Formatik unterrichtet haben oder zumindest es so anders versucht haben, das zu unterrichten. Und dann, ja, die waren wirklich nicht sehr erfreut. Zu der Zeit war so ein installieren dieses Novelnetz da irgendwie nicht so der Bringer. Da ist man dann schnell mal mit einer komischen Backup-Discette herangegangen und dann war die Sache erledigt. Was hat man das 40 Megabytes Festplatten untergebracht?
Also ihr habt euch sozusagen gegen die Installation bestimmter Software gewehrt?
Ja, ja, doch eigentlich schon.
Ich würde ja gerne noch wissen, was die disziplinarischen Maßnahmen waren.
Ja, ich auch.
Achso, aber jetzt nicht großartig eine Woche Hausarrest. Das kann man in der Schule gar nicht, Chaosrad gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Liebes Hintz, du kannst nicht gewesen sein.
Es war schon ein bisschen mehr, weil das war nämlich nicht unsere Schule, sondern eine andere Schule, wo wir zwei Abtrünnigen hingeschickt wurden. Die wollte uns halt nicht mehr haben. Man könnte auch Hausverbot.
Ihr hattet sozusagen Interesse daran, dass wir da auch nicht genommen werden.
Das war halt immer so ein weiter Weg dahin zu laufen.
Das ist einfach ein bisschen unwissend.
Oh, großartig.
Habt ihr da beim Programmieren fortgeschrittene Vientechniken benutzt?
Nee, das war ein ganz billiges Teil. Nichts irgendwie polymorphisch oder was sich da sonst wie verändert. Da hat diesen heuristischen Verfahren noch entkommen.
Das war ein ganz billiges Teil.
Also nicht so auf Virenscanner um Genen ausgelegt.
Wie hat er sich denn verbreitet? War der dann im Speicher und hat er sich in die Programme noch mit reinkuppiert?
Nee, das war ein Blutsektor-Virus. Es war ja noch so ein geniales System, dass die Laufwerke, die das Kettenlauferke gesperrt waren an diesen Kleinen. Und die konnte man dann mit irgendeinem Schneidernpasswort freischneiden. Und dann wurde die Diskette eingelegt und auf die Diskette das Teil gestartet.
Du hast den quasi verbreitet. Du bist analog rumgerannt.
Und dann? Und dann kopiert er sich und dann hast du ihn erstmal auf den Bootsektor kopiert und beim nächsten Mal booten wurde der irgendwie von der Platte gestartet.
Das war dann im Prinzip vor dem Bootsektor. Von dem eigentlichen Bootsektor hat den noch anders hin kopiert und dann wieder aufgerufen und die Standardsache halt.
Aber es war jetzt keine weitere Verbreitungsroutine drin?
Nee, das würde es ja auch nicht sein. In dem Sinne jetzt über das Netzwerk oder so. Wir waren viel zu aufwendig, das war nur so ein Spaß irgendwo.
Also mehr so eine Mine, die man irgendwie auf einzelnen Systemen installiert.
Ja, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ja, hat Spaß gemacht, hoffentlich euch auch damals. Wir haben jetzt übrigens...
Man merkt, der sportliche Ehrgeiz ist vorhanden.
Ja, aber ich finde, um in der Schule rum zu stressen, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen irgendwie.
Aber das ist sicherlich auch für viele Aktivitäten tatsächlich der Auslöser. Ich meine, wenn man irgendwie immer überlegt, was kann einen Jugendlichen heutzutage frustrieren, da würde mir ja irgendwie eine ganze Menge einfallen, wenn man erstmal das Thema Schule aufschlägt. Da sagt der Lehrer, du bist irgendwie das letzte Arschloch und dann kommt der Rutschnaut nach Hause und denkt sich halt nur, dir zeig ich's, du Wichser. Und dann geht's los. Und dann wird das Virus Construction Sit angeworfen und die neuerworgenen Assemblertechniken und tralala. Und es klingt ja auch immer wieder alles so kompliziert, aber wie wir schon mehrfach gehört haben, ist ja ganz einfach und nur ganz einfach. Man muss irgendwie noch gar nicht so tief drinstecken, so etwas zu schreiben, ist einfach. Von daher geht auch immer dieser Vorwurf, diese Verdammung an diese Leute, so ein bisschen ins Leere, weil die sind sich dieses Unrechtes wahrscheinlich in den meisten Fällen gar nicht bewusst. Sondern die schreiben das aus einem Affekt heraus, so wie andere Leute vielleicht ihre Hausfrauen, ihre Frauen erschlagen irgendwie. Leiten sie das dann irgendwie auf ein bisschen kraftfreies Begebenheit?
Ja, das klingt ein wenig, ja.
Das sieht man, aber wie auch immer, andere Leute schlagen ihre Fernseher ein, ist doch egal. Und im digitalen Bereich, da ist es halt etwas eleganter.
Das ist offensichtlich, ja. Wir hatten noch eben Gregor den Drahtzieher, jetzt haben wir den nützlichen Idioten der Weltregierung hier. Hallo Marvin. Du bist also der, der die Drecksarbeit machen musste, ja?
Na ja, ich hatte noch einen Quick C-Compiler, um hier rumzulegen, so ein 87 oder so. Und im Prinzip war das Ding ganz billig. Irgendwie hat das in die Outback C-C.bat irgendwas reingesetzt, was so einen Zähler hochgesetzt hat. Und dann sollte das nach 30 Boots-Vorgängen oder so einfach Format C oder so was ausfüllen. Und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, warum es nicht geklappt hat. Ich glaube, ich habe den Software ja nicht mehr. Ist es auch nicht, habe ich auch nicht behauptet.
Sondern, was ist es?
Ich weiß nicht, was man es dann durchgehen lassen soll, als irgendwas Schadenprogramm oder so. Also eigentlich, dass es sich fortschlägt und so halt nicht. Eine Mine.
Gab es eigentlich bei euch auch disziplinarische Maßnahmen?
Deswegen eigentlich nicht. Ich weiß eigentlich gar nicht, was er da jetzt meinte. Ich glaube, es lag an irgendwas anderem. Wahrscheinlich auch das weiß schon ein paar Jahre her. Wahrscheinlich waren meine Kenntnisse irgendwie da doch nicht so gut.
Und seitdem hast du es aber nie wieder gemacht. Und seitdem zahlst du auch immer irgendwie brav.
Deine Rundfunkgebühr.
Und das Ticket in der U-Bahn.
Nee, eigentlich hab ich da eigentlich nicht mal weiter gemacht. Im Moment bastel ich an einem Trojaner für Windows.
Hat der irgendwelche interessanten Features?
Ich hatte das mir eigentlich so gedacht, also das Ding läuft als Webserver im Prinzip. Das heißt, dass man überall einfach mit dem Browser rangehen kann, sich dann da einloggen kann, über so ein ganz normales Fensteraufkommen, den man an den Passwort eingibt. Und dann im Prinzip davon, von dem Rechner eben erst mal Dateien hoch und runterladen kann, Befehle ausführen kann und so eigentlich ganz grob.
Hast du schon mal darüber nachgedacht, vielleicht einen guten Virus, ein gutes Trojanisches Pferd zu schreiben? Irgendwie was...
Spendet? Oder was meinst du mit gut? Ich hab ein Trojaner geschrieben, Spendet Automat.
Das ist technisch versiert für Fisticated, sozusagen.
Ich mein, du könntest ja auch auf fremden Rechnern Keys berechnen lassen oder dort Sicherheitslöcher fixen oder keine Ahnung. Da gibt es garantiert eine Menge Möglichkeiten.
Naja, die Idee bei Virelinter war ja eigentlich eine andere.
Also es ging jetzt viel mehr darum, dass, sozusagen, eventuell so an ein paar Arbeiten oder so früher ranzukommen oder so.
Hausarbeiten. Hausarbeiten. Quasi Lösungen.
Ja, beziehungsweise, also die Lehrer geben ihre E-Mail-Adressen eigentlich zu relativ, ohne Weiteres, eigentlich an die Schülern weiter bei uns.
In welcher Sprache schreibst du das? In welcher Sprache programmierst du das?
Also das hab ich jetzt im C++ mit.
Bitte?
Wie machst du deinen Rechner von deinen Lehrern denn ausfindig, wenn sie sich denn ins Internet verbunden haben?
Da hab ich mir eine Klasse geschrieben, die hab ich IP-Manager getauft, hab ich mir teilweise vom Bio2Gaze-Sourcecode abgeguckt, der im Prinzip, sobald die IP ändert, eine E-Mail rausschickt an mich, beziehungsweise kann man ja auch über so ein SMS-Gateway irgendwo laufen lassen und dann...
An dich ist es aber ein bisschen gefährlich, ne? An dich ist es aber ein bisschen gefährlich, ne?
Ja, ich weiß, das hab ich mir natürlich auch überlegt mit dem SMS wahrscheinlich eben noch nicht, aber...
Da gibt's doch diesen pseudonymen SMS-Anbieter.
Das gehen wir immer noch an ihn.
Das ist die Nummer, da drin steht irgendwo.
Und das mit der E-Mail wird halt sicherlich auch...
Obwohl, hey, natürlich geht das, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Du kriegst in Neukölln, hab ich das bei diesen Ankauf-Verkaufläden, da kriegst du gebrauchte, weiß was ich, Free-and-Easy-Karten oder wie die heißen. Und die sind dann nicht mehr personalisiert. Und da kannst du dir deine Short-Messages hinschicken lassen. Also da hab ich mal so ein Ding gekauft, 20-mal um die Zahl.
Also nicht, dass wir da so aufrufen würden, dass du das tust, aber...
Nein, nein, nein, so ging das. Nee, das muss man aber nicht tun. Und nimm nie Drogen. Danke für deinen Anruf. Ja, mach's gut. Hier ist es Chaos Radio 63. Chaosradio 63 auf Fritz, wir reden über Viren, das tun wir mit euch unter 0331 70 97 110. Uns interessiert insbesondere die Motivation fürs Viren schreiben. Also wenn ihr schon mal probiert habt Viren zu schreiben oder aktiv schreibt, ihr könnt auch gerne anonym bleiben, ruft uns an unter 0331 70 97 110. Die Motivation interessiert uns und auch gute Fragen wie die von Sebastian. Hallo Sebastian. Was ist deine gute Frage?
Meine gute Frage ist ja, ich hatte schon mal selber ein Virus gehabt und konnte den dann allerdings beseitigen mit so einem Virusprogramm, so einem Anti-Virus-Programm und wollte mal fragen, wie es eigentlich erkannt wird, also anhand der Namen oder es war dieser CIH. Virus und das Virusprogramm hat dann einfach gesagt, so ich habe jetzt ein Virus und der hat so und so viele Dateien gefallen und das konnte ich dann beseitigen irgendwie. Aber für mich ist das relativ unlogisch. Also ich beschäftige mich so ein bisschen mit Programmiersprachen, allerdings mit Perl oder mit Javascript und da sind die Möglichkeiten halt nicht so groß und das wollte ich halt mal fragen.
Wie gesagt, es gibt da im Wesentlichen die Möglichkeiten Zeichnenketten, also eine Anzahl von Bytes, die halbwegs aussagekräftig sind und die aus dem Virencode entnommen wurden und man kann danach suchen. Und die andere Möglichkeit ist, dass man nach auffälligem Verhalten von Viren guckt.
Genau, auch während des Betriebs. Das heißt, wenn Programme sich verhalten, wie man es von Programmen so nicht kennt, aber wenn man es von Virenprogrammen her kennt, sind viele Dateien löschen innerhalb kürzerer Zeit oder keine Ahnung, was würde euch da noch einfallen. Es gibt halt viele Firmen, auch so Virenlabors, die erst mal in der Uni ihren Beginn hatten, in der frühen Forschungszeit, wo einfach Leute den ganzen Tag da sitzen, alle möglichen Viren, die so auftreten, einfach analysieren, und zwar sowohl was sie tun, wie sie es machen, wie sie aufgebaut sind, und eben dann natürlich auch, wie man sie erkennt. Und diese Erkennungsmechanismen bauen sie in ihre Scanner-Software ein, das heißt, sie können halt ganz konkret das Aufreten an einer bestimmten Datei erkennen, indem sie einfach da einen Vergleich machen, mit Check-Summen, da wir mal schnell rübergehen, und eben auch bestimmte Konstruktionen erkennen, die darauf schließen lassen könnten, dass das vielleicht unter Umständen ein Virus ist.
In der neueren Zeit, und besonders bei Wurmern, macht man es auch, dass man den Netzwerktraffic analysiert nach bestimmten Strings. Weil zum Beispiel dieser Code Redworm hat einen ganz charakteristischen HTTP-Request, den man sehr leicht erkennen kann.
Dazu muss ich dann aber das Netzwerk überwachen? An welcher Stelle?
Das kann jeder auf seinem Router machen.
Also das kann man überall da machen, wo Internet-Traffic vorbeifließt, also entweder zu Hause, auf einem eigenen System, wenn man das selbst installiert. Aber es wird auch von Internet-Service-Providern gemacht. Es wird auch teilweise schon als Dienstleistung fertig angeboten, dass man irgendwie Internet bekommt mit irgendwie gleich mit ohne Virus. Also zumindest behaupten sie das irgendwie, wobei dann natürlich auch völlig unklar ist, was sie tun, was sie rausfiltern, was sie tun, wenn sie etwas rausfiltern, ob sie das kommentarlos tun, oder ob man da in irgendeiner Form von Entkenntnis gesetzt wird.
Was heißt mein ISP überwacht, sämtlichen Traffic, der zu mir geht?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das da einer tut, aber das wäre durchaus möglich.
Wird's gemacht schon?
Ja, es wird als Dienstleistung angeboten, du kommst halt irgendwie für DMX mehr. Das überzahlt sozusagen auch noch gleich die Sicherheit. Das ist so ein bisschen wie eine Versicherung im Prinzip.
Ja, aber die lesen meine Mails dann mit im Zweifelsfall.
Das tut sie sowieso.
Ein interessanter Aspekt dabei ist natürlich auch, dass man natürlich Verschlüsselung einsetzen kann, um das zu verhindern. Hat aber natürlich immer den Nebeneffekt, auch wenn ich am Gateway gewollt nach Viren suchen will und ich im Internetverkehr verschlüssel, dass das Gateway dann natürlich die Viren nicht mehr erkennt. Dass man hier also sich sicher glaubt, die Sicherheit aber der Wirklichkeit nicht vorhanden ist. Das ist ein echtes Risiko, ein echtes Problem.
Das könnte auch denkbarerweise von einigen Firmen einfach so gehandhabt werden, dass sie sagen, naja, wenn wir halt Viren nicht erkennen können, wenn verschlüsselt wird, dann wird einfach aus unserem Netz nicht verschlüsselt. Das ist zwar eine sehr radikale Methode und manche Unternehmen werden das halt auch nicht machen, weil sie Verschlüsselung brauchen, wenn sie mit ihren Kunden kommunizieren. Aber für speziell öffentliche Einrichtungen wie Bibliotheken oder Schulen, wo man halt möglichst wenig Stress haben will, ist es schon denkbar.
Es ist schon denkbar eine andere Möglichkeit, die auch angewendet wird und die auch ihre fragwürdigen Seiten hat, ist zum Beispiel Key Recovery. Sprich, der Kleinen kann zwar die Kommunikation verschlüsseln, aber das Gateway hat halt den Schlüssel zum Entschlüsseln und kann an den Verkehr sich trotzdem anhören und sehen. Das kann natürlich A genutzt werden, um nach Viren zu scannen, aber kann natürlich auch zur Überwachung genutzt werden.
Sebastian, soweit beantwortet?
Da tauchen wir in einen ganz interessanten Bereich rein. Auch im Club hatten wir da wilde Diskussionen, wie man in die Situation real einschätzen soll. Es gibt auch viele verschiedene Meinungen. Manche sehen natürlich auch gerade diesen Viruswahn als weiteren Wegbereiter zur Förderung der Contentüberwachung. Vor allem der Akzeptanz der Contentüberwachung, so frei nach diesem Schema nach, was gegen was Böses ist. Das muss ja was Gutes sein. Wie wir das auch schon bei Kinderpornografie hatten, und irgendwie die Idee, Webseiten rauszufiltern und böse Links und all diese Geschichten, wie es findet jetzt auf einer Ebene statt, wo es einfach mal an den gesamten Traffic überhaupt, der zu einem geht, führt. Virenscanner Software, die automatisch installiert ist, gibt es ja auch explizit Unterstützung in den Produkten. Nicht beim Microsoft Exchange Server gibt es...
Ja, der hat eine API dafür, wo sich die Virusprogramme direkt reinlegen können, die Anti-Virus-Programme.
Also es ist auch genau dafür vorgesehen, dass die eben da eingreifen und die nehmen dann irgendwie den I love you raus. Aber wenn du halt dann tatsächlich mal von deinen Angebeteten irgendwie so eine Mail bekommen hast, die du schon seit Jahren schmachend wartest, und dann kommt die Viren-Software und wirft den raus und du wirfst dich irgendwie von Zug.
Das ist ein excellenten Comic von User Friendlies.
Ganz ehrlich sagen muss, die meiste Anti-Virus-Software ist schon intelligenter. Die entfernt dann wirklich nur das befallene Attachment. Die meiste.
Chaosradio 63 auf Schrittzimmern noch um 20 nach und nach sozusagen. Und am Telefon ist Boris. Du kümmerst dich um die Firewall deiner Firma.
Ja, so kann man es sagen. Also ich mach eigentlich tagsüber im Firmennetzwerk bei uns so ein bisschen den Admin, auf keinen Fall hauptberuflich, aber ich halt von uns ein, so sag ich mal, am besten kann, mach ich halt. Und kümmere mich einmal Firewall mäßig drum, einmal am Client in der Personal Firewall, aber dann aber auch bei dem Linux-Router, der das gesamte Netzwerk steuert, wo halt ein simples IP-Chains draufläuft und dann auch so ein bisschen Anti-Viren-Software, das kann ich tagsüber in der Firma alles implementieren und wenn mich dann was interessiert, dann sitz ich abends zu Hause an meinem privaten kleinen Zweirechner-Netzwerk und probier dann Sachen aus und so.
Dann schreibst du die Viren, um deine eigenen Sicherheitssysteme zu umgehen?
Nee, ich häng dann abends um 20 nach 12 bei Fritz und erzähl dir, wie gut das alles klappt.
Na wie gut klappt denn das?
Also, das hab ich mich eigentlich auch gerade gefragt, wenn ich so ein bisschen bei euch in der Warteschleife hing, weil, also eigentlich klappt es ziemlich gut. Ich hab in der Firma bisher interessanterweise noch überhaupt kein Problem gehabt, was Viren oder Würmer oder irgendwie sowas in der Art anbelangt, weiß aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich nicht, liegt es daran, dass ich mich so gut schütze oder liegt es daran, dass mich keiner angreift? Und die Fragen konnte ich bisher noch nicht beantworten.
Habt ihr keinen I love you bekommen?
Nee, der ist bei mir nicht angekommen, aber bei mir ist vor zwei Tagen, das ist eigentlich wirklich das allererste Mal, ein Virus angekommen. Das war, der Absender war anjahoffmann at irgendwas.de und ein englischer Text, irgendwie vier, fünf Zeilen, hello und an, weißte nicht, an bei, irgendwie die Datei und ich stell dir mal ein Projekt vor und würde mich freuen von dir zu hören, was du darüber denkst.
Solange es nicht Tanja Nolde war.
Und das Ganze war dann irgendwie als betreff Puchel oder so und dann war das Attachment halt eben auch puchel.xls, also eine Excel-Datei, Punkt VBS und naja, gut, als schlauer User, also ich meine, ich brauch kein I love you zu bekommen, um zu wissen, dass war das VBS dann eben nicht öffnet und dann hab ich mir angeguckt irgendwie über den Quelltext der Mail, wo die Mail dann herkam und dann war das interessanterweise halt eben auch eine Domei aus deutschen irgendwas und dann hab ich mir die Homepage angeguckt und es sah dann nach einem Online-Dienstanbieter aus.
Guck mal in das Dokument rein, das ist bestimmt echt spannend. Also du musst den Virus extrahieren und dann kannst du dir das Dokument anschauen und da ist bestimmt was interessantes drin.
Ja, mittlerweile hab ich... Du grinst, du grinst, warte mal Boris. Lisa grinst gerade so deckig. Was vermutest du, was da interessantes drinstehen könnte?
Ich meine, wenn es von irgendeiner großen Online-Firma ist und eine Excel-Kalkulation ist, kann das schon irgendwie...
Ach so.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Und Puchel könnte natürlich irgendwie deren größter Kunde sein oder so.
Ich dachte, du hast reingeschaut in das Ding.
Also mich hat es dann nicht irgendwie weiter interessiert. Aber was ich gemacht habe, und das fand ich mal irgendwie ganz spannend, weil das war echt sehr nah an der Realität dran, ich bin halt eben auf die Website des Absenders gegangen, weil das war einfach auf der Domain der E-Mail zu erkennen. Hab gesehen, das ist halt eben ein Online-Dienst der Anbieter. Und dann habe ich erstmal die Mail zurückgeschickt, nachdem ich... Und dann noch mal, hey, ich habe hier gerade eine Mail von uns. Das ist auch so mein Standardding, wenn ich von irgendjemanden, den ich nicht kenne, eine Wortdatei bekomme, die ja gelegentlich als ungefährlich eingestuft wird. Und sag auch standardmäßig, ich weiß nicht wer du bist, ich weiß nicht was du mir da schickst. Und wenn du mir was schicken willst, dann schickst du mir halt das Mail. Und ich als Wortdokument, das geht genauso gut.
Und an bei hast du noch meinen Körner.
Und na auf jeden Fall in dem Fall habe ich dann die Mail zurückgeschickt und dann bekam ich eine automatisierte Reply-Mail vom Mail-Server dieses Dienstanbieters, der mir doch dann glatt sagte, sie haben uns ein Virus geschickt.
Das funktioniert sozusagen nur in die eine Richtung.
Jaja, genau.
Wer war das?
Ich meine, dir ist klar, dass nicht mich unbedingt gesagt, dass das auch wirklich von dem kam, der als Absender E-Mail adresse.
Ja, natürlich ist mir das klar. Und natürlich ist mir das klar. Also wie gesagt, ich beschäftige mich mit dem Thema ja auch so ein bisschen.
Es könnte ja sozusagen auch die Absicht gewesen sein, dass er es an verschiedene Leute schickt, eben mit der Absenderadresse, damit die das alles wieder an den zu verschicken.
Ja, vielleicht war es auch mehr noch ein Wurm als ein Virus, weil er hat sich ja offensichtlich automatisch über das Telefonbuch von Frau Anja Hoffmann verbreitet. Auf jeden Fall der große Gag war dann halt einfach, weil mich das irgendwie neugierig gemacht hat, und ich es auch irgendwie ein Ding fand, dass von so einer Firma bei mir einfach eine Mail eintrudelt, habe ich dann da angerufen.
Und gab es Anja Hoffmann?
Ja, es ging also jemand dran und es war offensichtlich die Sekretärin, und sie sagte, Firma Tralala Hoffmann. Und ich so, oh, sind Sie Frau Anja Hoffmann? Und sie so, ja. Und dann dachte ich, ich hab gerade eine Mail von Ihnen bekommen. Und sie so, oh nein, Sie auch? Und da hab ich ja kurz umgesagt, Sie haben aber hoffentlich die Datei nicht geöffnet, oder? Ich bin auch nicht voll bescheuert. Und das war's dann halt einfach gewesen. Und sie sagte, ja, wir arbeiten da dran an den Problemen. Und wir wissen auch nicht, woher das gekommen ist und warum, wieso, weshalb. Und das war's dann halt einfach. Ich fand's halt einfach witzig, wie da so ein bisschen auflaufen zu lassen.
Aber der Satz, ich bin ja nicht so bescheuert, war natürlich echt cool, weil es nämlich heißt, dass die so bescheuert war, draufzuklicken.
Ich hab's mir dann auch irgendwann gedacht. Ich dachte, irgendwie muss das Ding ja getriggert worden sein, bei ihr auf YouTube.
Bei ihr haben wahrscheinlich den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Leute alles gerufen, die irgendwie gesagt haben, was denn das soll.
Tag Frau Hoffmann in ihrer Kalkulation ist ein Fehler.
Na ja, da kann also durchaus die Motivation gewesen sein, dass Frau Hoffmann irgendwie Freunde hat, die jetzt keine guten Freunde mehr von ihr sind oder sein wollen.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall, das funktioniert irgendwie ganz gut. Ich hab hier in der Wohnung bei meinem Bruder, er hat eben auch einen Rechner und dem hab ich da neulich mal einen McAfee draufgeknallt. Da sind dann auch gleich irgendwie drei Sachen gefunden worden. Das hat mir dann auch gezeigt, dass meine Personal Firewall, die ich hier hab, also das ist hier wirklich nur ein 98 Rechner, der eben nackt im Netz hängt sozusagen. Deswegen auch die Personal Firewall. AdGuard nebenbei bemerkt, mit dem ich sehr zufrieden bin. Und deshalb hat mein Rechner einfach auch mich erwischt. Und da hatte ich dann schon mal so ein bisschen das Gefühl, hey, da hast du dich ganz gut geschützt irgendwie in letzter Zeit. Auf meinem Rechner hier zu Hause zum Beispiel hab ich auch keine Virensoftware laufen, einfach gar nicht. Und in über zwei Jahren ist auf meinem Rechner nichts Großartiges passiert. Ich hab in der Zeit übrigens auch niemals mein Windows neu installieren müssen. Auch ein weit verbreitetes Phänomen. Vor allen Dingen jüngere Menschen, die mir erzählen, dass sie alle drei Monate ihr Windows neu installieren müssen, weil irgendwie gar nichts mehr funktioniert.
Aber das liegt daran, dass du mal irgendwie vier Computerspiele installiert und die installiert hast.
Ja, ja, aber rauf, runter, rauf, runter. Ich hab auch mal jemand gekannt, der hat alles einfach nur, der hat seine Root-Verzeichnis Müll halt genannt, statt C sozusagen, und hat einfach alles da rein installiert. Egal was es war.
Das war mal ein Experiment und gucken, wie lang es dann läuft.
Das ging ziemlich lange, anderthalb Jahre. Ja, hat einfach alles da reingekloppt und irgendwie so. Na gut, aber das nur nebenbei. Auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie eine ganz interessante Umgebung und ich würde eigentlich gerne nur noch mal wissen, greift mich in meiner Firma eigentlich keiner an oder mache ich es eigentlich nur so sicher? Und ich hab so ein bisschen hin und her überlegt und dann mich dann eigentlich doch entschlossen, euch jetzt nicht die Web-Adresse von mir zu verraten. Ich glaube heute können viele interessierte Leute da sein, die mir das vielleicht beweisen würden, das ist alles gar nicht so sicher. Ich hab aber auch noch eine Frage. Und zwar, bei dieser ganzen Geschichte ist mir irgendwie so aufgegangen, relativ oft springt halt meine Firewall an und sagt mir, da kommt ein Port-Map oder da kommt ein inbound oder outbound Traffic-Versuch, eine nicht genannte Anwendung, immer halt eben dann NA, auf irgendeinem kryptischen Port, von irgendeiner IP, irgendwo her. Und dann weiß ich halt einfach nicht, was ist das jetzt? Ist das irgendwas, was das System macht, was sinnvoll ist? Ist das einer, der mich von außen irgendwie scannt? Ist das was Automatisches? Ist das ein...
Ich würde sagen, das ist jemand, der durchs Hotel geht und an den Klinken rüttelt. Das ist jemand, der durchs Hotel geht und an Klinken rüttelt.
Ja, um halt eben zu gucken.
Genau, was ist denn da? Viele Leute haben Portscanner laufen, und das erwischt dann jeden irgendwie mal.
Gar nichts Böses, sondern um einfach zu gucken, mit wem man es da zu tun hat. Du Portscans an dich soll niemand in Panik versetzen. Wenn du deine Feierruhe richtig konfiguriert hast, dann ist das alles gar kein Problem.
Sie nervt halt dann einfach rum, weil sie dann immer mal sagt, Bing bong, da kommt was.
Niemand behauptet, dass ich halt befähm ist.
Deswegen sind ja Systemadministratoren auch immer so genervt, wenn sie irgendwie gescannt werden, weil eben ihre Systeme gleich die Flagge hochmachen, obwohl eigentlich gar nichts Stimmes passiert.
Ja, in der Firma stört es mich nicht, weil da hängt ein Linux-Router davor, auf dem läuft IP-Chains, so ganz eben wie auch Wunder gesagt hat, wunderbar. Erstmal ist alles verboten und dann sind halt eben nur ein paar Sachen erlaubt. Und da kriege ich dann auch nicht gleich irgendwelche Hilfe-Mails von meinem Server, nur weil irgendjemand einen Podscan macht, da stört mich das nicht. Zu Hause ist das eine ganz andere Geschichte. Da lasse ich die Firewall-Thema an und wenn dann halt einfach ein Podscan von irgendwo kommt, muss die Firewall auch zwangsläufig anspringen. Das kann ich auch glaube ich bei Edgar nicht irgendwie unterbinden, dass er das automatisch wegblockt. Das kommt, das heißt die Firewall poppt ab.
Hast du eine Statistik zu Hause?
Ne, aber einfach eine ziemlich gute Flatrate.
Aber auch keine statische IP-Adresse? Ok, aber du hast schon einen dynamischen DNS für dein System aufgesetzt. Immer wenn du verbunden bist, bist du erreichbar unter einem Namen? Du kriegst nur deine IP-Adresse dynamisch.
Ne, das ist auch kein fester DNS. Das ist eine dynamische IP. Man kann ja auch mit einem dynamischen IP...
Ich meine, wenn man mit einer dynamischen IP arbeitet, kann man sich ja dann auch dynamisch diese IP sozusagen unter einem festen Namen regelmäßig updaten lassen. Aber das machst du nicht.
Das mach ich nicht. Und manchmal ist es halt einfach nervig. Ich weiß nicht, ich spiele ein schönes Computerspiel, bin mitten lang und zack, knallt mir die Firewall irgendwie an und mich aus dem Spiel meistens raus. Und sowas zum Beispiel. Das ist dann halt einfach nervig.
Wenn du online bist, also du spielst im Netz Eier?
Ja, Counterstrike zum Beispiel. Und wenn dann die Firewall angeht, dann fliege ich mit 80%iger Sicherheit auch aus dem Spiel raus. Weil dann bin ich auf Hindustsebene. Und bis ich dann irgendwie das geblockt habe und dann wieder zurückwander, dann bin ich einfach aus dem Spiel raus. Das ist dann ein bisschen streffig.
Wie Lisa sagte, niemand hat gesagt, dass Sicherheit bequem ist.
Mit Sicherheit nicht. Aber meine Frage ist eben auch nochmal, wenn dann halt eben so ein Scan kommt, ich bin dann halt einfach auch neugierig und ich hab auch irgendwie den einen oder anderen, die eine oder andere Software, gibt dann ja jetzt irgendwie OSTRO, Softnet oder so, ist halt einfach dann so, hat alle möglichen Features, da geb ich halt eine IP ein und dann macht der ein DNS Lookup und meinetwegen auch noch einen Podscan und guck dann, was da so los ist und sagt mir dann, also wie gesagt, DNS Lookup auch noch und so. Das ist aber meistens alles ziemlich wenig aus... sage ich kräftig. Dann guck ich mal an und weiß da noch mal eigentlich nicht so besonders viel drüber und schon gar nicht, ob das jetzt ein harmloses ein harmloser Podscan war oder ob da irgendwie mehr dahinter steckt. Und das würde mich eigentlich noch mal interessieren, weil ich hab eigentlich immer noch das Gefühl, ich mach irgendwie die Schild hoch und ab und zu mal kommt halt was vorbei, aber ich kann nie so richtig mal, also nicht, dass ich ein aggressives Potenzial hätte, aber ich denke irgendwie so, ich kann nie mal richtig mal zurückschießen oder wenigstens zurückgucken.
Du kannst ja IP-Adressen irgendwie von denen.
Ich meine, du kannst zurückscannen und gucken, ob dir das was bringt, aber meistens sind es ja wahrscheinlich auch eher dynamische IP-Adressen.
Aber in dem Moment gelten die ja dann auch. Du kannst natürlich auch schon was Automatisches ausessen.
Ja, ich meine, es ist wahrscheinlich auch davon auszugehen, dass jemand, der einen Portscan macht, wohl auch eine Firewall dran hängen hat. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Portscan mache, dann kriege ich genauso viel zu sehen wie der, nämlich so ungefähr gar nix.
Nicht unbedingt gesagt. Hängt dann vielleicht von der Administration des Schulnetzwerks ab.
Also das einzige, was du erkennen kannst, ist, wenn nach so standard-offenen, also nach Standard-Trojaner-Ports wie von Sub7 oder Backorifiles gescannt wird, dann kannst du halt relativ sicher sein, dass jemand einfach ein ganzes Subnet abscannt oder so und nicht unbedingt dich meint, sondern einfach...
Das findet aber statt, es wird viel gerüttelt da draußen. Aber Red Noise ist normal.
Genau, ich muss euch jetzt leider unterbrechen, denn wir müssen Nachrichten machen.
Kann ich aber noch mal drinbleiben? Ach komm, nach 5 Minuten höchstens.
Was ist mit den anderen, die noch in der Leitung hängen, Boris? Okay, 3 Minuten kriegst du nach den Nachrichten. Bleibt dran, okay, bis gleich.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 8 Grad.
Zwei nach halb eins.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
In der Nacht gering bewölkt, oder klar die Temperaturen sinken auf 13 bis 9 Grad. Tags wieder ein sonniger Tag bei Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 26 und 30 Grad. All your base are belong to us. Die Meldung mit Falk Zielge.
Atomkraftgegner haben am Abend bei Straßburg den größten Kastortransport von Deutschland nach Frankreich vorübergehend aufgehalten. Mehrere Deutsche und Franzosen ketteten sich an die Gleise. Mindestens fünf Blockierer wurden festgenommen. Die zwölf Behälter mit 60 Tonnen Atommüll rollten danach über die Grenze. Neun Behälter kommen nach Laak, die drei übrigen ins britische Sellafield. Der Vorsitzende des Zentrallrats der Judenspiegel hat die umstrittene Plakataktion zugünsten des Berliner Holocaust mannmal als missverständlich kritisiert. Das Plakat mit dem aus dem Zusammenhang gerissenen Satz den Holocaust hat es nie gegeben, war in den vergangenen Tagen heftig kritisiert worden. Ein Holocaust-Überlebender stellte Strafanzeige wegen Volksverhetzung. Diesen hatte Spiegel allerdings völlig überzogen. Die polnische Armee hat einen 50 Meter breiten Durchlass in einen Deichabschnitt der Waiksel gesprengt. Damit soll die Überflutung weiterer Ortschaften verhindert werden. Die Behörden sprachen von einer leichten Entspannung der Situation. Das italienische Parlament wird den umstrittenen Polizeieinsatz beim G8-Gipfel in Genua untersuchen. Gleichzeitig stellte sich die Mitte-Rechtskoalition von Ministerpräsident Berlusconi hinter ihren Innenminister Skyola. Eine deutliche Mehrheit lehnte im Senat einen Misstrauensantrag der Opposition ab. Zum Sport. Im Halbfinale-Rückspiel des Fußball-UI-Cups trennten sich Wolfsburg und Troyes 2 zu 2. Damit erreichten die Franzosen das Finale. Als zweite deutsche Mannschaft schied 1860 München aus, die Münchner verloren gegen Newcastle United mit 1 zu 3.
Nur nur 34, vielen Dank Falk Zilding.
Unter den Linden, da sind wir zu finden.
Bei Peugeot Avenue, das ist die Show.
Ich sag jo, du kommst vorbei, einfach.
Du bist so fei oder hörst es im Radio.
Boris, drei Minuten hast du noch, die hab ich dir eben versprochen.
Also, eine Sache wollte ich noch erzählen und eine kurze Frage hab ich dir noch an den Chaos Club. Und zwar, also ich würd mal sagen, meine ganzen Erfahrungen aus den letzten paar Jahren könnte man in folgender These eigentlich zusammenfassen, wer einen Virenscanner laufen hat und Sachen scannt von Leuten, die er nicht kennt oder von Leuten, wo er denkt, dass die vielleicht nicht die Heldsten sind oder sich nicht vor Viren schützen, wer eine Firewall am Laufen hat und irgendwie sein Klein dadurch schützt und nicht irgendwelche Exo-Dateien oder sonstige Dateien, die er per Mail bekommt von Leuten, die er nicht kennt oder sogar von Leuten, die er kennt, der diese drei Regeln irgendwie so beherzigt, der ist, würd ich mal sagen, ziemlich sicher.
So, jetzt macht das mal jemandem klar.
Können wir unterschreiben?
Aber jetzt macht das mal jemandem klar.
Nicht nur die Antiviren Software, nein, es ist die Software, die man einsetzt, muss man natürlich auch up to date halten. Sprich, aktuelle Security Patches installieren, weil da hilft auch meistens die Antiviren Software und die Firewall nur begrenzweit.
Ja, aber wer das nicht macht, hat sowieso dann selber Schuld.
Ja, aber erklär das mal jemandem, der das Default Passwort, das der Admin für jeden Arbeitsplatz in einer Firma gesetzt hat, der das noch nicht mehr ändert. Und noch nicht mal eine Vorstellung davon hat, dass man dieses Default Passwort ändern kann.
Oder automatisch speichert, dass es in der PCIe hängt. Das ist natürlich auch klar so. Dann ist aber in dem Zusammenhang noch eine Geschichte, und die finde ich wirklich krass, und das wird auch glaube ich kleinartig ausgenutzt, was für Iana anbelangt. Die leichteste Möglichkeit, jemanden vor Iana im Netz zu verpassen, ist doch, ich labere mit irgendeinem im Irg, stelle irgendeine Geschichte, ich frage ihn, hey, was machst du denn für einen Sport? Und er sagt, hey, ich mache Volleyball. Und er sagt, ey, cool, ich auch, ich habe ein paar coole Bilder irgendwie geschossen. Letztes Mal bei unserem Volleyball-Turnier, soll ich dir mal schicken? Hö, schicke ich dir mal eben per ICQ rüber, oder per Irg, und dann schickt er ihm irgendeine Datei und sagt, weiß nicht, das ist, guck dir die mal an, dann versucht er die zu öffnen, und dann öffnet die sich nicht, weil das irgendwie korrupt, und dann war das halt eben der Trojaner, und dann kommt danach nochmal, sagt er gleich, hey, die Datei lässt sich gar nicht öffnen, und dann schickt er ihm eine Datei, die ist zur Öffnung, und ist irgendwie in Ordnung. Und dann schöpft er nicht mehr einen Verdacht. Und zack, hat der Trojaner drauf und hat einfach nicht mitgekriegt. Weil er sich einfach nur nett mit irgendjemandem im Chat unterhalten hat. Und das ist irgendwie eine ziemlich krasse Geschichte.
Also wenn es nach unserem Innenminister ginge, dann wäre das, was du jetzt gerade gemacht hast, Aufforderung zu einer Straftat, oder? Ne, eine Warnung. Genau, eine Warnung, diese DCCs nicht anzunehmen.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich, es findet einfach statt, Punkt. Deswegen ist jede Verdammung auch irgendwie immer wieder ein Problem, man muss halt schon irgendwie an den Wurzeln das Problem bekennen.
Und die Frage, die ich habe, und dann sind die drei Minuten bestimmt auch ganz schön... Der rungt jetzt schon um. Ich hab mir eure FAQs von CCC ehrlicherweise noch nicht durchgelesen, aber weiß nicht, wenn man bei euch mal vorbeikommt oder euch mal ein bisschen fragt oder sowas, kann ich denn auf solche Sachen bei euch auch Antworten finden und darüber auch sich unterhalten. Weil seid ihr so, dass ihr sagt, ne, ne, ne, wir sind jetzt hier nicht die Viren- und Trojanerschützer und so, wir machen halt andere Geschichten.
Na, wenn du mit so einer Erwartungshaltung ankommst, hey Leute, bespaßt mich und sagt mir, was Sache ist, sondern nicht mit Leuten unterhältst, die das Gespräch interessant finden, dann wirst du da sicherlich auch nicht rausgeschmissen werden. Also es ist halt eine Frage des Umgangs.
Ja, na klar, also ich wollte nicht den Nerd spielen, der immer fragt, ey erklärt mal, erklärt mal, erklärt mal und kann sich nochmal vorbeikommen.
Na, Nerds sind ja nicht so schlimm, aber...
Es gibt keine Garantien irgendwie, also wir beißen nicht unbedingt immer.
Boris, das war's. Danke für deinen Anruf, ciao.
Eine gute Gelegenheit, irgendwie Leute zu treffen, die man irgendwie interessante Sachen fragen kann und die auch irgendwie kluge Antworten zu geben in der Lage sind, gibt es übrigens in naher Zukunft, und zwar am 10. bis 12. August in Holland, genauer in Enschede, dort findet ihr Hell.
Zum großen Freigelände in der Innenstadt.
Einer der großen Freigelände an der Universität in Twente statt. Das ist halt ein dreitägiges Hackercamp, ähnlich wie das, was wir vor zwei Jahren schon mal gemacht haben. Das gab es auch vor vier Jahren schon mal und vor acht Jahren in Holland. Und das können wir eigentlich jedem nur ans Herz legen, da hinzugehen, wer sich irgendwie für Computer und Informationstechnik und die Auswirkungen interessiert. Da kommt alles zur Sprache. www.hell2001.org Ok, wir haben wieder ein Täter am Telefon.
We got signal from Daniel.
Gestehe.
Das war kein wirklicher Virus.
Ach komm.
Nee, das war damals.
Nee, ich wollte die Bank auch nicht wirklich ausrauben.
Meine Oma ist auch, nee, ist sie nie.
Du musst erst sagen, was sie ist, bevor du sagst, dass sie es nicht ist.
Nee, das war damals an der Schule. Ich hatte dort als einziger Zugang zum Infokabinett alleine, weil ich dort halt auch so ein bisschen die Computer mit betreut hab und so.
Infokabinett ist für Computerraum irgendwie, oder?
Für Informatik halt, so Computerraum. Und mein Informatiklehrer hatte immer dieses, die Reihenfolge erst Laufwerk A und dann C. Und der hat irgendwie gemacht, auch auf alles meinen Anraten hin und so. Und dieses kleine Dostool Debug, damit kann man ja auch so eine Art Skripte schreiben.
Das ist ein vollhaltiger Assembler? Doch du konntest damit auch, wenn du keine andere Möglichkeit hattest, einfach programmieren, also in Assembler.
Was hast du damit gemacht? Man kann jetzt auch die einzelnen Tastenbefehle in eine Datei schicken, reinschreiben, die dieses Debug kriegen soll, und schickt die dann mit so einem Dostpipe an Debug. Und da hab ich mir einfach mal den Bootsektor geändert. Und zwar, wenn man dort die ersten beiden Bytes auf ebfe setzt, das ist der Assembler, also der Maschinencode für Jump Zero, also eine schöne Endlosschleife. Und da hab ich einfach den Bootsektor geladen, auf eine Diskette auf der Diskette Sieheis gespeichert und dann die ersten beiden Bytes geändert, so per Patch-Datei. Und hab ne schöne Boot-Diskette draus gemacht, in der Autoexhibit hat er das gemacht dann. Und davon hab ich Kopien angesetzt und hab die in alle Rechner reingelegt.
Und alle Maschinen standen einfach still.
Beim nächsten Starten ging alles noch, weil da musste er das erstmal machen und dann ging aber nichts mehr. Und dann hat er die Boot-Rennfolge geändert.
Haben sie dich aber erwischt?
Naja, ich hab's ihm gesagt.
Ich war's, ich war's!
Naja, klare Technologiedemonstration. Glaubst du mir nicht, dann guck doch mal was passiert, wenn ich hier ein bisschen Plastik in dein Computer einführe.
Das ist doch irgendwie so, Herr Direktor, ich habe Ihre Tochter entjungfert und es hat ihr gefallen. Das ist total mies, oder?
Nee, ich meine, ich war mit dem Info-Lehrer dort, da war ich fast per Du. Er war Lehrer, deswegen nie, aber wir haben uns echt gut verstanden. Ich meine, mein ganzes Reden hat nichts gebracht, da muss ich ihn halt mal zeigen. Genauso auf Arbeit. Mein Master, der hatte dort zu Hause auf seinem Rechner unter Windows diese Datei Erweiterung bei bekannten Dateitypen ausblenden. Und das finde ich total wachsinnig. Und er hat mir auch nicht geglaubt, wie man das brauchen kann. Da habe ich mir halt auch mal so ein VBS da geschrieben und habe das als Text getarnt. Und jetzt hat er auch die Dateiendung da sichtbar.
Apple will das jetzt auch machen.
Daniel, wir haben noch drei in der Leitung, würden die gerne noch schaffen.
Alles klar.
Danke für deinen Anruf. So, nehmen wir mal noch einen Diskettenkunde.
Olaf.
Also ich finde das sowieso... Wer hantiert denn heutzutage noch groß mit Disketten rum? Das macht doch kaum noch einer.
Nein, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Aber das war halt so, ein Kumpel hat gesagt, das ist ein super Spiel und ich wollte es einfach mal haben. Und er hat auf Diskettenkunde kopiert. Und so toll wie ich war, hatte ich keinen Virenschutz drauf. Und dachte mir, da wird ja nichts passieren. Obwohl mich ein Kumpel schon mal gewarnt hat, da passt auf, bei dem sind manchmal Viren drauf. Ich im Vertrieb rein, fahre hoch, alles in Ordnung. Und war zwei Tage nicht am Rechner danach. Will wieder rangehen, der Rechner fährt nicht mehr richtig hoch. Meine Tastatur blockiert alles. Und mein Vater hat probiert, wir haben den Rechner auseinander genommen, nochmal zusammengesetzt. Also es ging gar nichts mehr. Und irgendwann haben wir eine andere Tastatur angesetzt. Dann ging die Tastatur wieder bei der Rechner standstill. Dann sind wir so weit gekommen, als wir das Unfall rausgekriegt haben, ja, irgendwas hat den Rechner gelöst, hat Windows gelöst, alles. Dann sind wir zu Vogels rüber und dann haben die uns geglaubt, wir haben es dann schön wie auf einen gefahren gehabt. Und haben uns erstmal alles wieder hochgefahren.
Und was hast du daraus gelernt?
Also ich starte mein Rechner jetzt, wenn ich jetzt immer Platten vor und so, fahr ich immer als zweites nach Windows immer sofort mit dem Virenscanner mit drauf. Damit mir sowas wie passiert ist, nicht nochmal passiert. Und das ist eine Lehre gewesen. Ich kann allen sagen, vorsichtig bei Disketten, wir werden uns Disketten benutzt.
In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank Olaf.
Ja bitte.
Jetzt haben wir noch, jetzt die Frage finde ich ganz interessant. Hallo Manfred. Stell mal deine Frage.
Ja, ist eigentlich nicht direkt eine Frage, aber ich habe in Testberichten gehört, in der CT war es drin, wurden Antivirenprogramme getestet. Und da kam raus, dass also Antivirenprogramme teilweise ausgehebelt werden von Viren. Also in der Registry, die Einträge werden aus der Kraft gesetzt. Also diese AV-Gards werden einfach deaktiviert, sodass der Virus dann also sich da verbreiten kann. Also da wird dann natürlich nicht mehr erkannt. Und da gab es also dieses Free-Antivirus, dieses H plus B EDV, was ich jetzt auch seit einem halben Jahr benutze. Und das hat also diese Tests überstanden. Wollte ich mal fragen, ob ihr da zu was sagen könnt?
Das hieß ja eigentlich, dass ich gegen eine gezielte Attacke machtlos wäre. Weil der würde einfach meinen Virenscanner möglicherweise irgendwie rauskriegen, dass ich über welchen Virenscanner ich laufen habe und den einfach ausschalten.
Das grundlegende Problem dabei ist einfach, A, Virenscanner sind nie 100%ig, werden also nie alle Viren erkennen. Schon einfach, weil erstmal die entsprechenden Signaturupdates gefahren werden müssen. Ein ganz anderes Problem ist, dass natürlich, wenn man sich doch ein Virus einfängt und den erstmal zur Ausführung gebracht hat, dass der natürlich alles machen kann, was der Benutzer auch machen kann. Wenn der Benutzer das Virusprogramm ausschalten kann, dann kann das der Virus letztendlich auch. Wenn jetzt das eine Virusprogramm im Test das bestanden hat, das mag erstmal ein gutes Zeichen sein, heißt aber nichts für die Zukunft.
Ist ja auch klar, was immer so eine Art Wettlauf zwischen den Antivirenherstellern und den Virenprogrammierern ist. Die natürlich versuchen, die Antivirensoftware auszutricksen. Die Antivirensoftware-Leute sind dann immer damit hinterher, wieder die Viren zu erkennen. Deshalb muss man halt immer gerade die aktuelle Version haben und ist dann auch immer noch nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Genau, und wenn eine Software irgendwie einem einzigen Virus irgendwie wieder strebt, wo alle anderen scheitern, dann muss man sich halt auch schon fragen, wo dieser Virus eigentlich herkommt.
Martin, äh Manfred, ich blöd Mann. Vielen Dank für den Tipp. Du hast uns Mut gemacht.
Zum Thema Mut machen können wir auch noch was sagen.
Ja, mach doch mal allen Mut.
Ich will mal allen Mut machen. Also die Würmer, also ich gehe jetzt mal auf die Würmer ein, weil die sind irgendwie interessanter, weil sie jetzt Service-Themen angreifen. Und die Würmer, die derzeit im Umlauf sind, erregen zwar viel Aufmerksamkeit, z.B. Code Red oder kürzlich waren es der Ramen und der Leyenwurm, aber sind nicht wirklich technisch versiert. Also sie sind schon ganz nett. Aber zum Beispiel der Ramenwurm besteht größtenteils aus ein paar vorgefertigten Exploits, um die ein Shellscript drumherum gebaut wurde. Virenprogrammierer, von Viren, die immer in die Öffentlichkeit kommen, geben sich halt nicht so richtig Mühe, hat man den Eindruck. Und da kann man noch ganz viele echt fiese Sachen machen. Und das Szenario wäre da so, dass es einen Schwenk gibt, wozu man Würmer und Viren benutzt, nämlich zur gezielten Verbreitung von Desinformation oder zum Suchen nach Informationen. Also wenn man den Zirkambirus nimmt und dem noch eine nur halbwegs intelligente Texterkennung gibt, dann kann er gezielt in den Dokumenten auf den Rechner suchen und dann nach bestimmten Schlagwörtern wie Quartalsabrechnung oder was auch immer und dann die Dokumente entsprechend rausschneiden.
Das heißt, ich hätte noch nicht mal einen Schutz, wenn ich irgendwelche kryptischen Dateinahmen verwende. Ich schalte ihm das, was sie verwendet.
Dein Anakonikower Archivfolger ist quasi schon auf dem Netz.
Ich habe Anakonikower geklickt.
Ich habe nur ein Beispiel. Man kann da so richtig, richtig gemeine Dinge tun. Und wenn Stichwort dieser Cyberwar Hype, kann man die Würmer natürlich auch prima benutzen, weil die halt effektiver, also bestimmte ganz einfache Sachen effektiver machen wie nach Exploits, halt scannen und sie ausnutzen und sich auf Systemen installieren. Da ist nicht unbedingt ein Mensch für erforderlich. Und wenn das so kommt, dann ist zu erwarten, dass die Virenprogrammierer auch technisch versierter werden. Stichwort Paranoia. Ich nehme an, dass die drei Buchstaben an den USA schon fleißig daran arbeiten. Allerdings wird man die dann sicherlich nicht erkennen, weil sie sich schon Mühe geben, sich ordentlich zu verstecken.
Das bringt mich auch noch mal auf ein anderes Ding, was man durchaus erwähnen sollte. Ein großes Problem sind ja auch Programme, die man explizit auch wirklich möchte. Nämlich Softwareupdates zum Beispiel des eigenen Betriebssystems. Und es setzen sich da gerade so ein paar, als werden Technologien verwendet, wie zum Beispiel das Signieren dieser Softwareupdates, das sozusagen Verschlüsselungstechnologie benutzt wird, um sozusagen sicherzustellen, dass das auf jeden Fall genau das offizielle Systemupdate von einem bestimmten Hersteller ist. Das kann man dann entsprechend auch überprüfen. Auf jeden Fall schon mal einen Schritt nach vorne. Und könnte eben dazu beitragen, dass man dem vertraut, sofern dieser Hersteller in der Lage ist, seine eigenen Schlüsse irgendwie ausreichend zu schützen und nicht er selber noch durch die Gegend zu schicken. Das ist glaube ich Microsoft, wo so etwas passiert ist.
Das war nicht Microsoft, sondern die CA. Ich glaube, Forger oder Veri-Sign, einer von den beiden war es, der das verursacht hat.
Das waren Keys von Microsoft.
Das waren Keys von Microsoft, die sie rausgegeben haben.
Okay, letzte Runde am Telefon. Hallo Sebastian. Du bist der Letzte, mach ein gutes Wort draus.
Ja, ich wollte noch ein bisschen Feedback geben, zu sogar drei verschiedenen Leuten hier. Zum Letzten jetzt Manfred, was er da angesprochen hat, dass die AVP und die Firewalls auch, das wird dann wahrscheinlich der Firekiller zweitausend sein. Das ist jetzt auch ganz neu irgendwie. Und der macht auch wirklich alles kaputt. Das ist wirklich böse. Und dass er da gesagt hat, dass in Antivirenprogrammen davon nicht getroffen wird, ist ganz klar, weil es werden natürlich nur die Großen gekillt, die bekannt sind. Die werden erkannt und werden auch so emuliert. Zum Beispiel das eigene Narzisstreffer oder so. Das ist ganz böse.
Weißt du doch in welcher Zeitschrift das war? Also in welcher CT-Ausgabe?
Och nee, das hab ich irgendwo im Internet.
Also es war noch nicht so lange her, ich hab die kürzlich beim Aufräum erst weggeschmissen.
Und dann das mit dem xls.vws, dass er die in den Dateien angekriegt hat, das war ja sicher der Zirkampirus. Wo er angerufen hat und dass er das nicht hinkriegen, das ist...
Hatten wir ja schon diagnostiziert und die entsprechenden Maßnahmen vorgeschlagen, aber er hat das Dokument ja schon...
Ja, den habe ich auch eben mal gekriegt.
Und, weil was Interessantes drin war?
Siebenmal oder achtmal hintereinander, von eben einzeln.
Fast wie ein Überraschungsei, war was Interessantes dabei.
Aber das an dem Zirkamp-Virus ist gar nicht mal so uninteressant, dass der erstmal in der Schleife läuft. Und scheinbar hat der, der mir das geschickt hat, dann war nicht gemerkt, dass irgendwas ist.
Hast du dir die Dokumente dann mal angeguckt, die der Zirkamp-Virus dir geschickt hat?
Naja, ganz bestimmt nicht. Ich bin ja nicht blöd. Es war ja immer Doppelendung und so. Aber wer auf Doppelendung einfällt, der ist wirklich ein bisschen...
Du sollst ja nicht draufklicken, sondern mit einem... Ich weiß nicht, wie ein Hexeditor oder so reingucken.
Hast du nicht gemacht?
Es war ja ein großer Teil, und die sich dann ein Texteditor angucken, nee danke. Das war auf jeden Fall der CCC und Virus und der hat sich ja immer mit verschickt und so. Und vor allen Dingen auch immer verschiedene Betreffende oder so.
Aber wem's gefällt. Sebastian, danke für deinen Anruf.
Nee, da war noch einer. Ja normal, also zu dem Boris, der hat doch Edgard. Ich hab auch Edgard und wir wissen es ganz genau, der schlägt so an sich auf Portscanner nicht ein. Wenn ich mal Portscan. Also da muss er entweder diese Calling Home Programme schön zu loben haben oder eben dass er wirklich was, womit der Angreifer da irgendwie connecten könnte. Also normal auf Portscanner schlägt Edgard eigentlich nicht ein.
Also ist das was da reinkommt böse oder?
Nö im Prinzip nicht. Eigentlich könnte es eher so sein, dass er ein Haufen Calling Home Programme hat, also die sich mit ihren Herstellern verbinden wollen. Das ist ja auch sehr beliebt. Da sind ja alle möglichen Programme unmöglich.
Alles klar Sebastian, wir müssen Schluss machen. Danke für deinen Anruf. Ja, das war Chaosradio 63 auf Fritz. Vielen Dank Lisa, vielen Dank Tim, vielen Dank Martin und vielen Dank Chris. Ihr könnt jetzt sowas sagen wie Danke Holger. Es war schön. Das nächste Chaosradio wieder am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Das ist diesen Monat, ich glaube der 29. August dürfte das sein. Also das ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat auf jeden Fall, wo das Chaosradio dann kommt. Einen schönen Abend noch. Hier gibt es ab 1 den Nightfly mit Martin Petersdorf bis Ende des Monats.
Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB.
Produziert in Babelsberg.